So, ich muss mal gucken, wie ich das jetzt managge hier.
Hallo Leute, Holzfäller-Skin wieder am Start, heute aber der rote Holzfäller-Skin, ich
glaube das letzte Mal war der grüne Holzfäller-Skin, so und ich hab immer noch ein Problem,
ich hab ja meinen Technikraum umgewurstet, die letzten Tage über, also letzte Woche
auch, und irgendwie, ich hab keine Ahnung was ich gemacht hab, hab ich mich irgendwie
verrenkt dabei, ja und ich hab übelst, mir tut übelst der Hals weh und ich hab Kopfweh
und alles, aber es geht, es geht gerade halbwegs und ich hab mir, komm ich mach jetzt einfach
mal streamen bevor ich einfach nur hinsitze, das heißt es kann sein, also wenn ich zu sehr,
wenn ich zu sehr Kopf weh hab, mach ich streamen aus, aber wir machen heute was, was ich schon
ne ganze Weile mal machen wollte, und falls ihr euch wundert, falls ab und zu mal immer
noch die 3D Druckerdämpfe, nee, da hab ich ja kaum was benutzt, falls sich einer wundert
wenn mal ab und zu hier so ein Handtuch ins Stream reinbammelt, das hab ich mir so im Hals
gehängt, weil das, weil das macht, das hält quasi hinten so die, so das Knick warm, ja,
dann, Wuppault brauchen wir jetzt mal im Chat, easykiller 17 Monate Dankeschön für den
Sub, und ich hab aufgerüstet Leute, ich hab jetzt da, da, das seht ihr nicht so richtig,
übrigens falls wieder irgendwelche Leute ankommen, das ist alles von der Katz, ja, also ich schneide
mich nicht regelmäßig selber, gibt ja sowas, aber bei mir ist das alles von der Katz, und
da, da hab ich jetzt ne Vorschau hier hinten an der Wand, ist ne Vorschau, das heißt wenn
ich hier rumwurste, dann seh ich auch direkt was ich mach, und ob ihr das auch seht, da
muss ich mich nicht so, was kann ich heute nicht machen, wenn mir der, wenn mir der quasi
rücken wie tut, so rüber gucken auf den Bildschirm, das funktioniert nicht, so, also, so, dann
versuch ich euch jetzt mal kurz zu erklären, äh, das mit dem Handtuch ist aber echt hardcore,
äh, unpraktisch, dann versuch ich euch jetzt mal die Heizdecke, nee sowas hab ich doch
nicht, so, also, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was dabei rauskommt, das heißt wir werden
heute wirklich ein bisschen basteln, und hat jemand noch den, den, den Stream wo ich den
Switch gemoddet hab, ich hab den aus Versehen gelöscht, jetzt kein Witz, ich wollte, ich
wollte was anderes löschen, und ich hab auch ein paar aus Versehen bei dem Stream in den
Comments, äh nicht in den Comments, in den Details, ich hab den Switch Mod Stream, hat
denn noch jemand, da würd ich, da würd ich, ja ab und zu mal gerne paar Sachen noch rausschneiden,
da waren nämlich nice Sachen dabei, also falls noch jemand den Switch Mod Stream hat, dann
sagt Bescheid, gibt's auch Subgift, falls ihr nicht schon habt, hat keiner ja das Sack,
dann gut kann man nix machen, Pech gehabt, gibt ja noch ein paar Clips draus, hier das
Stream ein Erlebnis, danke schön, zwei Monate Sub, so Leute ich mach jetzt wirklich mal
das Handtuch weg, das ist ultra, ultra, aber das bringt schon was, da bleibt das, bleibt
echt am Hals viel wärmer wenn ich das Handtuch drum hab, ich lass jetzt das Handtuch ja,
so ich zeig euch mal was wir krassen Hacker-Mans heute machen, vielleicht muss ich erst mal
mit was anderem anfangen, und zwar ich hab im Keller zwei, zwei Stromzähler, und zwar
einmal einen alten sowas, hat mit dem Auto glaub ich nix zu tun, so ein Teil, das kennt
er wahrscheinlich noch, der ein oder andere, sind so die oldschool Dinger, hallo kann ich
nicht einfach das Bild größer machen, so einer hängt bei mir im Keller, und äh so
ein neuer, ich hab zwei Dinger, ich hab für den ersten Stock so einen, und ähm so einen
ähnlichen hier, und auf, für, für den gesamten hab ich noch den alten von den, von den Stadtwerken,
die Dreh-Dinger, genau, so, und der hier auszulesen ist relativ easy, der hat eine Infrarot-LED,
der was weiß ich alle 0,8 Kilowattstunden blinkt, ne, den müssen wir aber auch auslesen,
und der hier, den müssen wir auch auslesen, und ich habe aktuell sowas am Laufen unten
im Keller, das heißt ich weiß, dass das funktioniert, ich mach das mal hier groß, ich weiß, dass
das funktioniert, wie man das ausliest, und es gibt zwei, es gibt zwei Ansätze sowas
auszulesen, warum hast du zwei Stromzähler, naja, das ist der von den Stadtwerken, und
ich hab oben für den ersten Stock noch einen anderen, den lesen die Stadtwerke nicht aus,
der ist halt dazwischen, dass ich sehe, was ich oben im ersten Stock verbrauche, der hat
mit den Stadtwerken nichts zu tun, das ist der, auf den es ankommt, nachdem abgerechnet
wird, so, und es gibt zwei Varianten, wie man den Kram ausliest, das heißt mal gucken,
wie weit wir heute kommen, aber ich weiß schon, welche funktioniert, weil ich hab ja unten
sowas ähnliches schon im Einsatz, und zwar, die erste Variante ist, man versucht irgendwie,
das hier regelmäßig abzufotografieren, und dann OCR zu machen, klappt, wahrscheinlich,
wenn man Platz hat, und eine halbwegs ordentliche Kamera davor machen kann, die man scharf stellen
kann, Raspberry Pi Cam oder so, klappt wohl ganz okay, das hier mit OCR auszulesen, es
klappt, aber, was ich mache, da zeig ich euch auch gleich die Hardware für hier, deswegen
haben wir auch die Kamera wieder am Start, basteln wir ein bisschen, was ich mache ist,
ich lese aus, wenn das durchläuft, weil hier ist ja immer so ein Strich drauf, ich meine,
ihr habt das wahrscheinlich, die Boomer unter uns, also so meine Generation, die hat das
ja wahrscheinlich schon öfters mal gesehen, oder die meisten haben ja sowas immer noch,
wenn das durchläuft, dann kommt immer mal zwischendrin so ein roter, oder so ein Strich,
ich mach den nicht auf, warum soll ich den aufmachen, da ist grad der Witz dabei, dass
ich den dann aufmachen will, warum nicht einfach einen eigenen digitalen Zähler einbauen,
weil ich da nicht dran will, und bis mal ein Elektriker kommt, das wieder 30 Millionen
Jahre dauert, so, also, hier läuft das Strich durch, so, und was ich jetzt habe, ich zeige
euch das mal, wir gucken uns nämlich noch ein bisschen die Hardware an, wie ich mir
überlegt habe, dass wir das, das kann sich auch nicht entscheiden, ob das da oben jetzt
die Brille anzeigt oder nicht, also, ich zeige euch mal was, chat, übrigens, ich hab nur
eine Vorschau von mir selbst, also ich hab hier auf dem Display leider keine Chat-Vorschau,
das muss ich mir nochmal überlegen, dass ich da irgendwie Chat-Vorschau, weil ansonsten
sehe ich das immer nur rechts auf der Seite, das sagt ein bisschen, so, deswegen zeige
ich euch mal die Hardware, wie ich mir gedacht habe, dass wir das ganze machen, aktuell ist
es ziemlich easy gelöst, ich hab unten an die beiden Zähler mit Klebeband zwei Sensoren
dran gepappt, mit den gleichen Sensoren werden wir das heute auch machen, aber das hängt
so auf halb acht an den Schrank geklebt dran, das ist nicht schön, ich stelle dir einfach
ein Tablet dahin, ich hab hier ein Tablet stehen da, aber auf dem Tablet ist die Vorschau
von der Kamera, dass ich den Kopf nicht so verrenken muss, um die Vorschau zu sehen,
aber ich sehe den Chat ja schon immer wieder, wenn ich mal zwischendrin reingucke, also
es ist wichtig, wenn du mal so ein Ed Wubblos dabei schreibst, so, ich zeige euch mal,
wie ich mir gedacht habe, wie wir das ganze realisieren, ich hab hier mal so eine Vera
Box von meinen Joker Schlüsseln, die sind ganz praktisch die Vera Boxen, weil die sind
ziemlich robust, so, also, das ist mein billig China Multimeter, das werden wir heute auf
jeden Fall brauchen, weil ich traue der China Hardware nicht, dass sie das macht, was da
drauf steht, die Chinesen nehmen es da nicht so eng, also, das brauchen wir heute auf jeden
Fall schon mal, die Chinesen aus China, was ist denn das, warum hab ich mir das hier reingeschmissen,
na gut, da können wir es dann später irgendwie festklemmen oder so, klemme, klemme, exquisite,
das mache ich hier aber mal weg, weil sonst wird es zu viel auf dem Tisch, so, also das
ist das erste, da haben wir ein paar Kabels, die brauchen wir auf jeden Fall, paar Jumper
Kabel brauchen wir auf jeden Fall, so, dann habe ich ein ESP32, zwar einen Tiny Pico ESP32,
die Dinger sind Massive Pock, die sind klein und brauchen nicht viel Platz, glaub mal,
erkennt man ganz gut, wo ist denn hier die Kamera nochmal, da, also, da siehst du, das
ist nicht sonderlich viel, ihr seht mein Finger, der hier eine Kratze hat, aber, so, das da
oben ist übrigens die WLAN-Antenne, diese silberne, und hier unten kann man auch Batterien
dran machen und sowas, so, das ist ein Controller, den wir vielleicht dafür verwenden, bin mir
nur jetzt sicher, ich hab noch ein bisschen Abfall, hab ich mir auch mal irgendwann gekauft,
auch einen anderen ESP32, und wenn alle Stricke reißen, ich hab auch noch einen ESP266, also
Controller hab ich genug da, so, das ist das eine, ich geh mal davon aus, wir werden den
verwenden, ich will keinen ESP266 verwenden, weil ich finde, die ESP32 lassen sich viel
angenehmer programmieren, viel angenehmer mit arbeiten, ja, naja, das ist, hast du auf
dem Raspberry Pi mit Desktop oder ohne, meinst du auf dem da, da ist Ubuntu Server drauf,
den brauchen wir gleich, weil, ich bin, also, wie gesagt, Leute, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
wie weit wir heute kommen, also, ich werde mal umgedreht anfangen, übrigens, danke für
die ganzen Subs, ich hab nur gesehen, dass der Scamtrain am Start gewesen ist, ich hab
nicht weiter mitverfolgt, ich war gerade zu sehr am erzählen, jebaited, jebaited train,
hier ist Ubuntu Server drauf, das werden wir später zum Flashen verwenden von diesen Dingern,
wir werden das hier am Desktop programmieren und dann Flashen Remote über den Raspberry
Pi, weil ansonsten müsste ich hier quer durch den Raum mit dem USB Kabel legen, das ist
ein bisschen doof, also, wie gesagt, wir gucken mal, wie weit wir heute kommen, wir werden
heute das zusammen basteln, das Programmieren weiß ich nicht, ob wir das heute machen oder
ob wir das vielleicht an einem anderen Tag machen, aber die Sensoren einstellen und so
können wir schon alles machen, genau, also, haben wir hier einmal zwei ESP32, weiß ich
nicht genau welchen ich verwenden werde, die sind auch noch komplett ohne Pins und ohne
alles, müssen wir mal schauen, so, dann sortieren wir das mal ein bisschen, legen wir die mal
hier oben rein, so, die USB Kabel lege ich auch mal neben hin, das muss hier nicht unbedingt
gerade auf dem Tisch liegen, so, einmal Schraubenzieher, brauchen wir auf jeden Fall, Netzteile, wir
nehmen das hier, das hier ist nur ein 12 Volt Netzteil und das hier ist zum Testen auf jeden
Fall besser, das hier ist eins, das kann man einstellen von 3, 5 bis 12 Volt, das ist ganz
nützlich, das ist so das Bench Power Supply für Arme, ist der Mauszeiger, oh, was macht
der Mauszeiger da, Keg-Wade, er müsste mir sagen, wenn der da ist, warum blendet er sich,
sollte er sich nicht im Vollbild eigentlich ausblenden mit der Zeit, Keg-Wade, wenn ich
deine Stimme höre, ja, das weiß ich, aber das war eigentlich ganz gut, früher habe
ich mir gedacht, ah nee, wird es nicht mehr älter an und heute freue ich mich drüber,
so, genau, Netzteil, lege ich auch mal neben hin, brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht unmittelbar,
exzellent Mario Kart Musik, legen wir mal neben hin, dann, ich muss immer mal exquisite,
50 Jahre alten Whisky trinken, ah yes, nee, eigentlich ist es nur Saft, so, gut, paar
Kabel, mal gucken, was wir davon brauchen, so, und dann den ersten Sensor, den wir benutzen,
dieser Sensor hier, der ist dafür zuständig, das Auslesen vom Zähler zu machen, ihr seht,
dass der, wenn das iPhone mal fokussieren würde, iPhone, Fokus, please, exzellent,
der hat zwei Infrarot-LEDs, da hier, also Infrarot-Sender und Empfänger, Hallo iPhone, please, so, also
zwei Infrarot-LEDs und damit kann der erkennen, wenn eine Linie oder ein Rand, wenn sich was
ändert, das heißt, das Ding, das habe ich hier unten schon am Start, das funktioniert,
das richtet man auf das Drehding vom Zähler und das erkennt jedes Mal, wenn dieser schwarze
oder rote Bereich sich am Zähler vorbeidreht, so, das ist der erste Sensor am Start, das
Gute an denen ist, normalerweise bräuchte man ja nur das hier vorne, aber das hier ist
die bisschen, paar Cent teurere Variante, die hat hier quasi schon, die hat zwei Ausgänge,
die hatten einen analogen Ausgang, da kann ich mir wirklich eins zu eins die Werte anzeigen
lassen über den analogen Ausgang, das ist der, der nicht angeschlossen ist und, ja,
5 Volt, oder 3,3 Volt in, Ground und ein Digitalausgang, das heißt, hier kann man dann einstellen,
wie empfindlich das Ganze sein soll, dass es ein Signal gibt, das ist ein bisschen einfacher
zum Einstellen und damit zu arbeiten, anstatt, quasi Analog-Dinger auszulesen und dann zu
vergleichen, das heißt, man kann das auf jeden Fall einfacher ausprobieren, dann kann man
da zum Beispiel mal irgendwas nehmen und dran vorbei machen und gucken, ob es leuchtet,
so, das ist der erste Sensor, den brauchen wir um den Zähler auszulesen, dann habe ich
den nächsten Sensor, das ist, wie nennt man sowas, Fotoresistor, wenn es davor blinkt,
also wenn hier Licht, wenn hier Licht drauf fällt, dann erkennt er das, hier kann man
auch wieder einstellen, wie empfindlich der ist und damit kann ich die LED auslesen von
dem oberen Stromzähler, jedes Mal, wenn der blinkt, registriert das das Ding und dann
weiß es halt, dass 0,8 Kilowattstunden rum sind oder so, weiß ich auch, was mein Zähler
steht, das muss man erstmal kalibrieren danach, also bei mir, ich habe noch keinen Brief
gekriegt, dass die den austauschen wollen, diesen komischen Zähler, ich hätte schon
den vor Jahren austauschen lassen, aber bisher wollten sie nicht und wenn, und wenn, wisst
ihr was das geile ist, sogar neue Zähler kann ich easy damit auslesen, weil, wenn ich einen
neuen Zähler kriege, dann tausche ich einfach den Sensor gegen noch nen zweiten mit für
ne LED, fertig und schon funktioniert's, weil die Logik dahinter ist genau das gleiche,
bei jedem Signal einfach eins hochzählen, nee, ich hab noch keinen Smartmeter, du könntest
den Maus, oder Borders einstellen, also den Bildschirmrand, ähm, ja das Problem ist,
dass ich, der nur in der Mitte ist, wenn ich auf dem zweiten Bildschirm bin, ich glaub
das kann man damit nicht einstellen, so muss ich den immer wegschieben den Mauszeiger,
tatsächlich ist mir egal, ich kann das auf jeden Fall auslesen, so, dann haben wir noch
was am Start, hab ich noch nen ESP286, falls wir ihn brauchen, also ich persönlich würd's
ja am liebsten mit dem machen, weil die Dinger sich echt angenehm programmieren lassen,
äh, dann haben wir hier noch nen Spannungswandler, 12 Volt auf 3,3 Volt, angeblich macht er das,
aber, wo wir grad beim Thema China sind, ich muss mal gucken wo ich das liegen hab, Sekunde,
wo wir grad beim Thema China sind, ich hab hier noch so zwei Dinger, so, ihr seht, das
ist auch so, mehr oder weniger das gleiche Board, und mehr oder weniger, die hab ich
nämlich extra mal rausgesucht, und mehr oder weniger der gleiche Spannungswandler, und
ich zeig euch dann mal was, dass du China Teilen nicht trauen kannst, sag doch heute
ist wieder roter, roter Holzfellerskin angesagt, du kannst den Dinger nicht trauen, angeblich
hab ich gekauft, 12 Volt auf 3,3 Volt, und ich hol gleich mein Multimeter und messe das
Ding, und ihr werdet sehen, die Chinesen haben wieder totalen Mist erzählt, und das Ding
macht einfach gar nix, das hat 12 Volt in und 12 Volt out, also nen Spannungswandler
der nicht wandelt, keine Ahnung was mit dem Teil los ist, und ich war so doof, ich war
so doof und hab den Chinesen geklaubt, ja, und hab hier mal das Board dran angeschlossen,
und was hat's gemacht, psst, hat's gemacht, psst, der scheiß Gnome, psst, ja das Board
ist im Arsch, ich würd's euch demonstrieren, aber dann stinkt's hier drin, sobald ich hier
irgendwas dran anschließ, ich geh mal davon aus, dass da irgendwas abgeraucht, ich hab
keine Ahnung was daran kaputt ist, zumindest wenn ich das hier anschließe, egal ob über
die 5 Volt Pins, 3,3 Volt Pins oder USB, es raucht, es fängt an zu rauchen, das mach
ich jetzt net, das machts übrigens erst seitdem es mit diesem tollen Spannungswandler einmal
gemacht hat, psst, ja, also die Chinesen haben quasi 20 Euro Board, naa, 50 Euro Board
zerstört, das heißt, ähm, zeig ich euch gleich mal, dass du diesen Dingern nicht trauen
kannst, deswegen müssen wir mal ausprobieren ob man dem Ding hier trauen kann, zeig ich
euch gleich, so, Traumzieher dahin, dann haben wir noch die Packung da vorn, die brauchen
wir jetzt nicht, äh, dann hab ich mir überlegt noch als kleines Upgrade zu dem Dankeschön
für die Subs, ich seh grad den Bildschirm nicht, das Keller Kind, 4 Monate exquisite
Subscription, und als kleines Upgrade, ich hab nämlich heut beim Rumwühlen in der Kiste
noch nen billigen Temperatur-Luftfeuchtigkeitssensor gefunden, den werd ich auch noch anschließen,
dann hab ich unten bei mir im Schaltschrank im Keller Temperatur-Luftfeuchtigkeit, sollte
es mal irgendwas brennen, erfahr ichs dann wenigstens, ja, schade doch auf jeden Fall
nix, ich bin mir nicht sicher was es für einer ist, ob es ein DH, äh, DHT11 oder 21
oder 22 oder was auch immer ist, vielleicht ist jemand von euch so big brain, erkennt
das rein an der Optik, ich erkenne das nicht, ja, alles AliExpress natürlich, oder, oder,
oder, äh, Azz Delivery ist ein 11er, okay, oder Eats, die, die haben es richtig, die
haben es richtig verkackt, ne, die haben sich Azz Delivery genannt, warum haben die sich
nicht Eats Delivery genannt, die haben echt einmalige Chance voll, voll verkackt, so,
das muss ich mir merken, die Dinger hier, das sind, sind die Teile die kaputt sind,
kann man sich recht einfach merken, der ohne, der mit der verbogenen WLAN-Antenne ist kaputt
und das Ding, was nicht am Kabel hängt, ist kaputt, zeig euch jetzt gleich, dass es
Smoked
So und dann haben wir noch einen case für das ganze was wir dann zusammen basteln wir haben den case habe ich heute
gestern gestern habe ich den 3d drucker noch ausgedruckt und zwar einen case für
Das ist übrigens noch frisch aus dem 3d drucker mit support das muss dann auch rausbrechen hier also einen case mit deckel und
Hier hinten ausgänge für usb und strom und sowas müssen wir mal gucken wie wir da durchkommen
Vielleicht muss ich die bohrmaschine oder den dremel oder irgendwas holen um die leuchter noch ein bisschen größer zu machen müssen wir mal schauen
Und von der idee her ist es dann so hier vorne kommt ein display rein das display haben wir hier
Waren wir auf
Exquisite display so ein display
Liegt spiegelung
Genau das display kommt dann
Passt das überhaupt
Kegway das müsste passen
Kommt an der innen also von innen
Kommt das display dann da rein man sieht da hat hier sogar so
So füßchen dass man das ran ran machen kann wenn man das hier
Kann man das display da draufsetzen so display
Display dass die die dinger sind echt empfindlich das packe ich mal wieder ein
Das packe ich mal wieder ein
Packe ich mal wieder ein und verstecks
Hier in der kiste so dann haben wir hier noch ein paar jumper kabels und und gedöns
Und als letztes das werden wir dann auch noch brauchen
Ist hier so ein stecker
Da kann man dann
Mal kurz raus
Da habe ich da habe ich ein paar solcher
Letztes mal bausätze oder das ist hier so ein stecker fürs netzteil da kann man dann
Also von der idee so wie ich mir das gedacht habe ich habe keine ahnung ob das funktioniert
Kannste dann hier das netzteil rein das netzteil rein stecken
Also von der idee her wie ich mir das gedacht habe dass hier vorne machen wir raus das können wir übrigens klammer
Grad mal gucken ob der 3d drucker das auch ordentlich gedruckt hat
Gucken ob wir das hier irgendwie rauskriegen
Also wie gesagt hier vorne das display und hier hinten hier hinten hier hinten dann irgendwie
Okay, das passt definitiv nicht dadurch guckt euch das mal an
Da muss ich das muss ich aufbohren das passt da nie im leben durch guckt es mal null
Passt nicht
Das muss ich das muss ich auf jeden fall ein bisschen ein bisschen erweitern
Ich habe so ein paar kegelbohrer die sind dafür ganz praktisch
Müssen wir mal schauen müssen wir mal gucken ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher ob ich das heute schon ins gehäuse einbau
Oder ob ich das nicht einfach mal alles zusammen mache probiere ob es geht und dann baue ich es ins gehäuse ein das ist wahrscheinlich die bessere variante
Bist du irgendwo geerdet quatsch
Wer braucht sowas schon
Ich kann an die heizung greifen im zweifelsfall hier
Nein ich bin nicht geerdet also im zweifelsfall mache ich irgendwas kaputt
jolo
Erdung jetzt kommt es halt mal auf hier
Das hätte ja anscheinend von irgendwie professionell im stream also hier wird garantiert nichts geerdet
Genau und also die das kann man hier rein machen ob es kann man dann hier durchmachen auf der anderen seite schraubt man das dann damit fest
Gucken wir mal gucken wir mal
Gucken wir mal es funktioniert so jetzt zeige ich euch mal das maschinakram nicht trauen kann
Ich bin immer mega geerdet genau heute ich bin immer exquisite geerdet
So und hier oben kommt dann der deckel drauf der erstaunlich gut passt für ein 3d gedrucktes gehäuse
Genau ich erde das so sehe ich das auch ich erde mich erst ab 15.000 euro server 150.000 muss nicht sein
Aber ich ich erde mich erst ab 15.000 unter 15.000 wird nicht geerdet kannst du einfach auswechseln
So jetzt brechen wir das mal raus und hoffen das geht nicht kaputt wenn es jetzt nämlich kaputt geht das wäre ziemlich doof
Wenn ich das jetzt mal irgendwie rauskriegen würde einfach mal draufdrücken
Oh das hört schnell gut an
Ich glaube ich brauche mal eine zange hier ist auch noch ganz viel support und so drinne das muss ich auch noch alles rausbrechen hier
Ich glaube wir basteln erst mal lieber bevor ich das gehäuse noch kaputt mache
So also gehäuse exzellent handtuch am start
Das bringt aber echt was ist viel wärmer am hals wenn man so ein handtuch rum hängen hat
So was wollte ich euch jetzt sagen ich wollte euch zeigen dass die dass die chinesen fake teile bauen also passt mal auf
Hau mal das multimeter hier
Und jetzt passt mal auf china kram
So eingestellt ist das ganze hier kann man kann man umstellen wenn man will aber eingestellt seht ihr ja ist auf 12 volt
Sieht man das ja sieht man als netzteil ist auf 12 volt eingestellt
Und nun passt mal auf
Nimm mal das teil hier zieh das mal ab ich muss mir das jetzt merken dass da
Das da ist das ganze das ist das ist das was was funktioniert ja
So jetzt schließen wir das mal an also
Auf dem stecker haben wir da orange ist plus gelb gelb ist minus
Das heißt ich schließe es jetzt mal so an
Ja das heißt ich schließe es jetzt mal so an guck mal da orange orange geht auf v in
V in
Orange vorhin und gelb geht auf ground
Also wir haben alles richtig angeschlossen viel mehr kannst du also da kannst nicht allzu viel falsch machen beim anschluss von diesem kram
Was ist denn da für ein chip drauf kann man das nicht machen
Da für ein chip drauf kann man da was lesen
Du meinst bei diesem spannungswandler da
Ja tut euch leute ich tut tut euch kein zwang an ich zeig es euch mal also wer danach forschen will kann das gerne machen
Ich habe kein schimmer
Habt kein schimmer
So und jetzt schließe ich das mal an
Jetzt schließe ich das mal an und ihr werdet gleich sehen das ding tut auch so dass es funktioniert
Das ding hat nämlich dieser spannungswandler also eigentlich sollte der 12 volt auf 3,3 volt spannungswandlern das ding
So und jetzt schließen wir das mal an und ihr seht auch das ding tut so als würde es funktionieren ich schließe mal kurz an
Guck
Es sagt alles gut ich funktioniere ich leuchte und jetzt kommt der china chibate der chinesen chibate kommt jetzt
So ich muss mal gucken wie ich da am besten dran komme
Ich packe jetzt mal die dinger von meinem hol wir stellen das multimeter mal auf spannung messen ein kurz ent ent ent kabel ent kabel
So jetzt passt mal auf
Ich halte das hier einmal einmal an ground dran
Und jetzt halte ich das an den out fack jetzt halte ich das an den out wir machen das anders ich habe doch hier so ein
so ein klemmstelz dran
Aber wir machen das mal klemmsor wenn ich wenn ich schon eine klemme da hab dann können wir es auch damit machen
Genau der ESP braucht je nachdem 3,3 oder 5 je nachdem welche input man nimmt
Und
Das sollte 3,3 am out liefern macht es aber nicht so
Damit habe ich gekrillt ja ja ich habe das gekrillt aber nur weil ich den chinesen gekrillt habe
Und das ist jetzt auch ein klemmsor und ich habe jetzt auch ein klemmsor und ich habe jetzt auch ein klemmsor
Ja ja ich habe das gekrillt aber nur weil ich den chinesen geklaut habe so wie alter
Also haben wir am out pin dran so und jetzt halten wir mal wir machen es mal dran
Leuchtet jetzt halten wir das mal
Dran und ihr werdet sehen
Normalerweise sollten da 3,3 volt rauskommen und was kommt aus dem china spannungswandler raus
12,4
seht ihr das
Du kannst dem china kram nicht nicht trauen ohne dass das vorher mal ausprobiert hast
Da sollten 3,3 rauskommen und nicht 12
Die chinesen
Haben es gekillt
So und nachdem ich das gesehen habe ist auch kein wunder dass der abgeraucht ist weil
Selbst mit ein bisschen toleranz verkraftet der garantiert keine 12 volt input
Ja rip
Du misst doch aber das out aus dem netzteil
Ich messe das out
Ich messe das out hier da out
Out vom spannungswandler guck hallo iphone please focus da
Guck da in der mitte mess ich da wo der out ist an dem aus sollten 3,3 rauskommen
mache es aber nett
Also absolut excellent qualitäts spannungswandler aus china
Aber dass das ganze funktioniert kann ich euch zeigen wir nehmen jetzt mal anstatt
Diesem t-bay spannungswandler
Nehmen wir martin lege ich ganz weit weg dass ich den aus versehen auch mal verwende
Nehmen wir jetzt mal den hier von dem ich weiß dass der funktioniert so
Input ist das orange crown ist das gelbe
So da machen wir jetzt ich muss mal gucken dass ich doch richtig gemacht habe also guck mal chat chat ich weiß
Aber ich auf den chat verlässt ist man eigentlich verlassen aber
vorhin
exzellent vorhin orange
ground gelb
Beziehungsweise hier gelb minus
orange plus
Also ist eigentlich richtig kann man kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen
gut
So dann schließen wir das ganze noch einmal an und ihr werdet sehen diesmal kommen da tatsächlich
3,3 volt raus also so wie es eigentlich sein sollte
Ground
Tja gucke mal da der spannungswandler funktioniert
So sollte es eigentlich sein und ich habe beide den da
und
Den da die kommen aus der exakt gleichen packung
Exakt aus dem gleichen beutel die waren sogar zusammen die musste man noch voneinander abbrechen also die kommen vom gleichen fließband
Also sprich die chinesen haben es voll verkackt
Und dementsprechend habe ich dieses ding damit geschrottet weil ich den schien den china specs geklaut habe
Also was lernen wir daraus nie den china specs glauben?
So
Exzellent
Jetzt habe ich euch das auch mal gezeigt
Also traut traut den chinesen nicht
Zumindest den schiener den chinesen könnt ihr meinen wegen trauen aber nicht in china teilen
Und
Wo hast dir das exzellent angeeignet
Weiß ich nicht irgendwo hier auf twitch und wisst ihr was das schlimmste ist mittlerweile
Wenn ich wenn ich youtube comments gucke
Der chat redet ja auch schon so ich habe letztens youtube comments aufgemacht und die hälfte der comments waren irgendwie in der richtung
Exzellent big brain stonks thema habe ich auch in hat einer das färbt echt ab
Ach so ja das übrigens das sieht nicht nur so schäpp aus die oder die ist tatsächlich schäpp
So
Also
Okay, das habe ich euch gezeigt passt wunderbar
Jetzt kann ich euch einmal erklären was ich was ich so ungefähr vor hab zu bauen
Ich hoffe ich habe das richtige teil hier am start
Nicht das kaputte china teil
Ich habe ja mal auf twitter
Auf auf twitter sind die leute die sind besonders empfindlich sind immer
Ich habe bei irgend so einem china teil was was auch echt ganz ganz merkwürdig war und nicht richtig funktioniert
Ich glaube bei irgendeiner steckdose die ich flaschen wollte ich aufgemacht hab wo die wo die pins in drinne schon abgefallen sind und so was
Wo du kaum dran gekommen bist da habe ich auf twitter mal geschrieben so nach dem motto alter welcher chineser hat sich das ausgedacht
Da kamen die leute wieder ab auf twitter am start wie wissen wir ist der twitter ist immer super empfindlich was so was angeht
Max du weißt nicht dass das ein chineser war
Gut ich mein das ding ist von aliexpress also vielleicht war es auch spanier oder so
Aber die chancen dass wenn du es bei aliexpress bestellt ist ein chineser gebaut hat die sind nicht so
nicht so weit hin
Und ja
Man ja du kannst gar nicht sagen dass das jeder chineses habe ich auch nicht nur der dieses ding zusammen gebaut hat kacke gebaut
Und die haben nicht umsonst gerade bei aliexpress billig teilen den huf weg
Dass da viel krepp dabei ist du hättest chines innen hätt ich schreiben müssen ja das vielleicht vielleicht wäre das ok
Vielleicht war das auch noch ein kinderarbeitschinese sogar man weiß man weiß nie wobei wobei wisst ihr was ich was ich letztens gelesen habe die
chinesen die haben mittlerweile auch kein bock mehr die
komplett
gesundheitsschutz
gesundheits schädliche menschen verarbeitet menschen verachtende arbeit zu machen die
lassen sie jetzt die nordkoreaner machen
Weil die haben sie haben es nötiger
das heißt wenn die jetzt dinge haben die halt wirklich echt unter aller sau sind dann holen sie sich ein paar nordkoreaner und
Lassen die das machen weil die es halt komplett nötig haben also quasi das was der westen früher
Mit manchen chinesen gemacht hat machen die chinesen jetzt mit nordkorea
Ja
Letztendlich solange ich meine aliexpress teile billig krieg
Ne es ist schon echt kacke was da läuft ja es gibt ein paar reportagen drüber wo die leute in irgendwelchen käfischen wohnen und sowas
Es ist echt nicht schön
So also jetzt muss ich mir überlegen mit was fangen wir da an?
Ich würde sagen
Als erstes überlegen wir uns mal was für ein controller nehmen wobei die entscheidung ist schon gefallen wir nehmen den hier
weil ich die lassen sich erst nice erstes nice programmieren außerdem weiß ich da
auch dass die ganze art von dran funktioniert
auch dass die ganze art von dran funktioniert das sind ganz normale esp 32 allerdings in recht in so ziemlich der kompaktesten
Bauformen die man sich vorstellen kann dafür sind nicht alle pins draußen aber das reicht also wir brauchen für die sensoren
Kann ich kann ich euch ja mal zeigen was wir brauchen also wir brauchen
Dafür brauchen wir ganz normal
Einmal plus also einmal einmal vcc strom und
Und einen daten gpio pin also haben wir auf jeden fall genug von
Für den line sensor ist exakt gleiche plus minus gpio pin
Und für den hier auch exakt das gleiche plus minus gpio pin allerdings
Wofür wir ein bisschen mehr pins brauchen ist das display zeige es euch mal
das
Aufkommen raus ich will es nicht kaputt man die dinger sind echt mega fragil. Ja
Die dinger sind echt mega fragil. Ja
Habe ich mich irgendwo gespiegelt wieder
Wo habe ich mich gespiegelt im display wieder hier excellent
Naja zumindest für die displays braucht man ein bisschen mehr da sieht man es man braucht
Ob ich euch das zeigen kann gescheit
Exzellent
Man braucht crowns vcc
scl und sda
Das ist spi das ist irgend so ein übertragungs protokoll da es ist aber nicht weiter
wild weil der exakt schon zwei pins dafür vorkonfiguriert hat da muss man gar nichts machen da muss sie noch richtig anschließen also
Wichtig ist wo ich mir jetzt am anfang erstmal gedanken drüber machen muss wo ich mir selbst noch nicht ganz sicher bin wie wir es machen
Das heißt wir brauchen insgesamt
brauchen wir
Überlegen wir brauchen
Wie viel 3,3 volt brauchen wir einmal für den controller
Einmal für den also eins zwei drei vier fünf mal
ground und fünf mal
3,3 volt sehe ich das richtig ja
Glaube schon
Hmm wie machen wir das jetzt am besten
Also alles hier drauf stecken kann ich auf jeden fall nicht das ding hat bloß zweimal crown und einmal 3,3 volt das funktioniert nicht
Ich habe eine idee ich habe eine idee was wir machen könnten
Also in den breadboard passt er hier auf jeden fall nicht rein das heißt das fällt schon mal flach in das gehäuse das passt ja im prinzip
Nix rein außer display der controller und und ja das war es eigentlich
Welche kamera benutzt mein iphone das ist ein iphone xs xr x dings ich
Der chat weiß was ich für den iphone habe ich weiß das immer selbst nicht so genau nicht das ultrafette und nicht das neueste
Dann machen wir das jetzt mal ein bisschen langsamer
hab ich weiß das immer selbst nicht so genau nicht das ultra fette und nicht das neueste
Der autofokus ist schon ein bisschen zu sehr on point wenn ich mich hier mal so durch bewege dann dann wackel die ganz kamera
Vago klemme
Wie machst du die verbindung zum pc nein das mache ich das kann ich euch kurz zeigen
Die verbindung zum pc mache ich mit was das nennt sich obs linja
Das ist eigentlich total easy das ist ein getter projekt
iPhone xr okay
Das ist ein getter projekt das schiebt man auf irgendeinen webserver
Egal wohin wo wo wo man drauf kommt mit dem rechner von dem man streamen will und mit seinem telefon
Und das geht dann über webrtc als ich eigentlich das einzige was ich machen muss ist ich gehe mit meinem iphone auf die seite
Die ich hier bei mir gehostet habe dort wo der obs linja liegt
Und mit meinem rechner gehe ich auf die gleiche uhr und dann streamt das über webrtc über den browser die kamera
Also zwei vago klemmen
Das ist eigentlich keine schlechte idee
Ich weiß nicht ob ich vago klemmen habe mit fünf mit fünf dingern
Also ich lasse uns mal überlegen wie könnte man das machen also ich habe ich habe ich habe die noob variante die noob idee von mir ist folgendes
Wir nehmen einfach
Hier also ich will ja das ding hier verwenden als input fürs netzteil das können wir gerade mal kurz raus machen
Zweifelsfall löte ich löte ich nachher wieder ab oder soll das ja nicht so wild
also
Hier kommt ja auf komm raus
Hier kommt ja das netzteil ran wenn ich es im kopf richtig hinkrieg ist das hier ist das hier minus und das da plus in der mitte so
Ich könnte den kram hier dran löten
So das da muss ich übrigens raus machen das ist schwachsinnig dass das da
Übrigens so fette kabel bräuchte ich überhaupt nicht die stecken da jetzt bloß drinnen die werde ich einfach jetzt mal verwenden
so
Ich meine es in zwölf volt und ein paar milliampere da reichen ganz kleine furz drehchen aus
So also was ich mir gedacht habe was wir machen könnte entweder wir nehmen eine vago klemme
Aber ich glaube ich habe keine fünfer vago klemme ich bin nicht ganz sicher
Aber
Ich könnte einfach zwei ineinander machen oder so das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren das muss ich gleich mal gucken wo ich welche habe
Was man machen könnte ist folgendes ich habe keine ahnung ob das ob sich da nicht das elektrische herz jetzt cringen muss
Man könnte so was hier machen
Also ich könnte einfach das kabel hier so ab isolieren und macht das einfach da unten dran
Also das könnte man machen
Ja ich kann das einfach so machen
Ja ich gucke mal ich habe so einen vago klemme set doch
Ich hole das mal ich hole das mal schnell ich hole das mal schnell bin gleich wieder
So
Schauen wir mal
Also ich habe vago klemme und vago so steckdinger die steckdinger muss ich mal gucken wo die sind da könnten auch fünfer dabei sein also
Ja guck mal das ist natürlich noch schöner das ist natürlich noch ne ist wir gehen der scheiß hier auf
Alter dies ist die billigste kiste aller Zeiten
Ja das geht so was so ein könnte ich nehmen ja ja warum nicht ein viel nicer immer so was
Ja ich mache da immer den deckel wieder drauf weil ich kenne mich ich schmeiß das sofort runter wenn ich das wenn ich da kein deckel drauf
macht
Ja das müsste eigentlich funktionieren also von der idee her würde mir das dann so machen hier hier kabels
Die kabel sind echt fett oder ich meine
Ich könnte einfach ein paar dünnere kabel nehmen
Das sind ja das sind ja so welche das die sind das sind die die man sonst glaubt für 230 volt nehmen das sind diese ganz ganz
fette dinger
Richtig cute chat
Also das würde das würde reichen so wir brauchen also lass mal kurz überlegen wir brauchen einmal hier input von von dem ding wir legen das mal kurz so hinter
Also wir brauchen das da einmal einmal äh ground dann brauchen wir
Hier eins einmal ground zweimal
dreimal
Viermal
Oh fuck fünfmal
Das reicht nicht
Dann lasse ich dann lasse ich den da weg
Komm mal hier haben wir hier haben wir bloß noch eins zwei drei hier habe ich sogar nur vier ja ja
Das ärgert mich warum warum reicht das jetzt wieder nicht
Was ist hier los warum reicht das nicht
Stimmt stimmt der esp ja aber mit mit mit mit mit mit mit 3,3 weil habe ich das gleiche problem brauche auch jeder sensor
Und das kann ich nicht vom esp abgreifen weil der esp hat nur einen einen 3,3 pin
Oder ich nehme
Ok leute was was was mein dir ist die bessere variante das da oder oder eine zweite oder zwei zwei klemmen
Ich bin mal da umschlussig und das ist das beste mal
Was das ziel ist strom zähler auslesen und zwar folgendes einmal
Den neuen zähler kann ich mit so einer foto mit so einem photoresistor auslesen der blinkt an die led die blinkt
Hallo
fokussen blitz
Ja das ist einfach was ein bisschen komplizierter ist wo ich aber auch weiß dass es funktioniert ist so einen alten zähler mit so einer drehscheibe
Auszulesen mit dem sensor das funktioniert das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert
Zwei klemmen das heißt dann brauchen wir wie viel was brauchen wir da für eine klemme weil wie gesagt wir haben hier drinnen wir haben hier
Drinnen nicht viel platz wir schaffen das passt nicht guck mal ich kann dann mal mit ach und krach kann ich auf eine seite eine klemme machen auf die
Andere seite eine klemme mehr geht da gar nicht rein schauen wir mal was was braucht man da für welchen
Wir würden wir würden theoretisch
mehr das funktioniert nicht ich könnte ich könnte sowas hier machen
Dann hätten wir genug
Aber das passt nicht. Nein
Wobei das wird ganz schön eng das mit den klemmen
Das wird fucking eng sage ich euch hier gatschi bass eng wird das weil ich brauche das ja doppelt ich bräuchte
Ich bräuchte das ja doppelt das passt nicht rein richtig gescheites sack. Sag mal
Jetzt mag zwar nicht ganz so korrekt sein aber
Kann man nicht einfach in einsteckverbindungen zwei kabel rein machen
Ich meine wir reden ja hier nicht von irgendwelchen fetten kabeln sondern von dünnen
Das doch das doch die schönere variante
Da machen wir hier da machen wir hier auf die seite er muss da mal eine runde heißkleber holen dann machen wir auf die seite ein auf die seite ein
Aber hier alles kronz ran und hier alles ja das ist gut so machen wir das exquisite so so wird das
exquisite so so wird das
Heißkleber ja klar
Leute ich muss mal gucken ob ich nicht irgendwo ein paar dünnere trete habe die dinger sind viel zu fett also erstens viel zu lang und viel
Zu fett hier für hier drinne
Aber ich werde ich werde sich in die box einbauen ich werde es erst mal erst mal so dran machen
Und ich habe noch eine idee ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das funktioniert ich habe mir nämlich mal vorne also
Erst mal was man auf jeden fall machen könne ich löte den kram hier einfach dran und gut ist
Hier minus da plus und gut ist was man machen könnte was ich mir vor einer weile gekauft habe
Da warte ich nämlich schon mal drauf den kram auszuprobieren seit einer ganzen weile und zwar ich habe mir so ein set gekauft
Das ist eine kombination aus
Schrotten das passt nicht sehe ich jetzt schon dass es nicht passt so kombination aus schrumpf schlauch
und löten
Das wahrscheinlich auch in so einer china erfindung oder so
Und das könnte man dann quasi hier drüber ziehen und direkt verbinden das problem ist nur ich sehe jetzt schon
Das ist so kurz
Das ist so kurz das funktioniert nicht guckt das kriegt man nicht drüber gezwungen ja aber wozu
Schrumpf schlauch ist eh nur ist ist nichts
Yolo brauchen wir nicht
Kannst du auch abschneiden
Ja, aber ich glaube das funktioniert dann nicht mehr so gut wenn man das abschneidet
Weil die haben ja moment wo habe ich jetzt hingeschmissen
Bin ich jetzt blöd habe ich das habe ich das nicht gerade hier reingeschmissen
Kekwede
Und nee ich habe das hier wieder nie in das ding reingeschmissen
Genau das ist von kabel zu kabel gedacht. Ja
Näh das passt schon
Wenn ich das hier dran löten okay, okay, also dann mal folgendes
Okay, big brain time. Lasst mal kurz überlegen
Ich meine ich kann es ja wieder auseinander also
Ich kann es ja wieder auseinander lösen also
Einmal hier genau hier okay also von der idee her wird es dann so zack zack
Dann ich leg das mal dahin dass ich mir das ungefähr vorstellen kann wird es machen so hier unten kommt das strom dann rein
Plus minus
Dann muss ich in irgendeiner art und weise noch jemanden mitnehmen
Dann muss ich in irgendeiner art und weise noch hier meinen spannungswandler dran kriegen den spannungswandler verbinde ich dann mit
Klemm mit mit den klemmen und ein paar jumper kabeln oder so also irgendwie sowas da
Wer ist dann nicht schöner ich mache ein paar extra kabels anstatt diese langen jumper kabels dazu verwenden schon schon
Oder kannst du abschneiden ja also die dinger hier werde ich auf jeden fall mal halbieren das sonst zu zu zick
Wobei das halt seinen scham hat wenn ich die wenn ich diese jumper kabels da verwenden kann weil die lassen sich halt gut gut gut stecken
Auf den ganzen kram drauf ne
Ich meine ich könnte auch ich könnte auch kabels hier dranlöten einfach wird auch funktionieren da mache ich ja nur in der mitte da mache ich ja nur in der mitte
3,3 volt out hier drüber
Ja da machen wir das so dann schneide ich das kabel durch
Dann muss ich in irgendeiner art und weise noch jemanden mitnehmen
Dann muss ich in irgendeiner art und weise noch jemanden bridge
Dann muss ich in irgendeiner art und weise nur in deiner art und del Bertil
auf jetzt
verbinden
Und sind jetzt nochmal ne
Ne das kann ja so nicht, ich brauch hier ja Platz für die Kabels, links, rechts muss das rein.
So, so irgendwie, ne.
Hier vorne kommt dann das Display, das wird ganz schön eng hier drin sag ich euch.
Warte mal, das Display muss dann da rein.
Dann muss der Spannungswandel, ok, der kommt da unten irgendwo am Anschluss.
Warte mal, ich schmeiß den Kram mal rein, das könnte auch, das wird gar,
wobei das Display machen wir, ah Moment, das Display machen wir einfach andersrum.
Hier unten kommt dann der Anschluss rein, ich leg das jetzt mal nur hier hin,
dass man einfach mal so ungefähr ne Vorstellung hat, wie das dann später aussehen könnte.
Also hier unten kommt der Anschluss dann dran.
Dann kommt das Display rein, das Display machen wir so rum dran, das ist glaube ich besser.
So, das Gute ist, der ist so klein, der passt egal wie immer drauf.
Dann kommt das Display hier vorne dran, so.
Oder irgendwie dann, Moment, das ist falsch rum.
Das wird echt eng sag ich euch.
Gachi Bass, Alter.
Das wird ganz schön eng.
Aber, aber es sollte passen, also wenn man das ordentlich,
wenn man das ordentlich machen, sollte das eigentlich gut funktionieren.
Hier haben wir die Anschlüsse, da würde ich sagen, machen wir das so in die Mitte.
Ja ey, das geht, guck mal, den Kram können wir dann hier drauf machen.
Am Ende heißkleber ich den Kram eh fest.
Ja.
Plopp.
Soweit von der Idee her.
So, das heißt wir verzichten mal ein bisschen auf, weil wenn ich hier die,
wenn ich das alles mit solchen langen Kabels mache, dann ist das Ding voll.
Das wird glaube ich nix.
Ich brauche, ich brauche, ich brauche nicht so welche, ich brauche Kabel,
die ein bisschen flexibler sind und die ich abschneiden kann und dann dranlöten kann.
Das glaube ich sinnvoller.
Okay. Ich hole mal kurz, ich habe irgendwo so eine Rolle mit 5, 6 verschiedenen Kabelfarben
und ganz dünn und flexibel, das werden wir mal nehmen.
Die muss ich mal kurz suchen, wartet mal kurz.
Gleich wieder, gleich wieder back, falls ich den Scheiß finde.
Guck mal Leute.
Hab sowas.
Ich hab was gefunden, was auf den ersten Ausblick aussieht wie Kabel.
Wisst ihr was es ist? Das sind keine Kabel.
Wer weiß es, was es ist?
Es ist Drucker, 3D-Drucker, 3D-Drucker, Druckmaterial.
Okay, ich habe, ich habe, ich weiß, dass ich welche habe.
Ich muss noch mal suchen Leute.
Okay, ich habe, ich habe, ich habe, ich habe, ich habe.
Ja.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Musik
Naja, ich bin, ich bin halb im Flur. Kein Wunder, dass ihr mich nicht hört. Also ich habe ein paar Sachen gefunden, die könnten vielleicht was bringen.
Aber das ist nicht das, was ich gesucht habe. Ich habe noch ein paar kürzere Kabels und hier so ein paar dünnere.
Aber ich habe mir für genau sowas, und das ärgere ich, ich muss den Kram finden. Ich habe mir für genau solche Dinger mal so einen Pack gekauft, so sechs verschiedene Rollen, so kleine Rollen mit dünnen, flexiblen Kabeln.
Musik
Wo habe ich das? Wir machen einfach eine Umfragevorschlag. Ja, mach mal eine Umfrage, wo hat der Max seine Kabel?
Und dann, und dann können wir raten, können wir wetten drauf, also. Wir machen, wir machen so eine, wo man, man kann, okay, also lass mal überlegen, wo das, wo das sein könnte, also.
Gibt, gibt zur Auswahl. Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt, ähm, nice, wenn ich den Mod machen könnte, also.
Channel Points wetten, und zwar, es gibt, es gibt zur Auswahl, äh, wo hat der Max seine Kabel? Als erste, erste Auswahl ist, erfindet sie nicht.
Genau so eine Prediction machen wir, eine Prediction, so eine Prediction, wo man Channel Points setzen kann. Erste Auswahl ist, erfindet sie nicht.
So, zweite Auswahl ist, hier, irgendwo hier im Zimmer, irgendwo im, zweite Auswahl ist Arbeitszimmer, dritte Auswahl ist im Flur, ich sage euch jetzt überall, wo ich noch nachgucken werde.
Und, ähm, was kann man sonst noch predikten? Kann man predikten nur ja oder nein? Oder kann man auch predikten, wir machen ja oder nein Prediction.
Man kann nur zwei, okay, findet Max, findet Max die Kabel noch? Ja, nein.
Mach mal. Also, wie gesagt, ich hab so ein paar, ich hab mir so ein paar Rollen gekauft von, äh, genau für sowas, so ganz kleine flexible Kabel in sechs verschiedenen Farben.
Wie lange du suchst? Ich suche maximal zehn Minuten. Maximal zehn Minuten. Ab 15 Uhr.
Okay. Ja, ihr seid aber, Chet, ihr seid aber verdammt zuversichtlich.
Ihr seid echt zuversichtlich. Heinrich, elf Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub und Don't Cry So Much, 21, auch Dankeschön für den Sub.
Mods können nicht mitmachen, denn du kannst wahrscheinlich die Auswahl selbst eintragen.
Ich geb mir auch Mühe beim Suchen. Hä? Der Hype Train? Was will der Twitch von mir?
Okay, Leute, ich geh jetzt gleich suchen. Ich hoffe, ich finde die. Okay, wir haben prediktet, Leute, auf geht's.
Okay, also ich such noch mal schnell. Wo hab ich den Scheiß, Alter?
Ich finde gerade alles bloß nicht das, was ich suche.
Guck mal, vielleicht können wir damit was besseres bauen als mit den Camps.
Okay.
Ah, Leute, ich hab's. Ich hab's.
Excellent, ich hab's.
Warum ist das so ordentlich? Ich bin nicht ordentlich. Ich hab grad so rumgewühlt.
So, da hab ich's nämlich. Guckt mal, wir haben Orange, Orange, Braun, Blau, Rot, Lila, Ne, Violett. Wie nennt man das eigentlich umgangssprachlich?
Lila. Ja, Lila. Schwarz, Grau, Hellgrau, Weiß oder Dunkelgrau, Weiß, Grün, Link. Excellent, excellent. Beste, beste.
Okay, okay. Sehr schön. Das machen wir jetzt mal hier hinten rein oder hier hinten in die Eck. Wunderbar. So. Also, Hammer, Hammer gefunden. Bin ich erleichtert. Ich hab noch ein Predboard gefunden, was uns vielleicht, was, ne Mini-Predboard passt.
Oh, ho, ho, ho. Moment, Moment, Moment. Post-Champ, Post-Champ. Ah, das wär ja zu schön, wenn man das da rein kriegen würde.
Da wären alle unsere, unsere Stackprobleme gelöst.
Diagonal rein? Nein, passt nicht. Diagonal passt nicht. Das wär Poggers, wenn das reinpassen würde. Zu fett, pepo, fett.
Von oben rechts, da unten links. Ja, so. Oh, ne, ne. Geht nicht. Kriegst du nicht rein, dann bleibst du hier hängen, dort, wo das Display angeschlossen werden muss.
Außerdem haben wir da keinen Platz mehr für den Rest, ne. Es wär nice, wenn es passt, aber es passt leider nicht.
Und da was abzuschneiden, das glaub ich auch nicht so easy, die sind relativ robust. Das wär, das wär cool gewesen, hätte das Predboard reingepasst.
Ich mein, ich mein, das passt sogar vielleicht.
Ey, das ist echt close, ne. Das ist close as fuck, dass das reinpasst. Aber da haben wir gar keinen Platz mehr für.
Aber zum Ausprobieren ist das mit dem Predboard jetzt wahrscheinlich gar nicht so verkehrt. Da kann ich mir so ein Mini-Protboard nehmen. So. Tablet.
So, und das nächste, was man benutzen könnte, wär irgendwie sowas, die oldschool, die oldschool Lochkarte.
Die könnte man nämlich nehmen hier. Das ist gar keine so schlechte Idee, ehrlich gesagt. Da haben wir mehr Platz als die Klemmen.
Das finde ich gar nicht so übel hier. Da lötest du dich halt jetzt erstmal ein bisschen kaputt, ne. Also das könnte man machen.
Die schneide ich einfach durch mit dem... ey, das machen wir. Ich glaub, wir nehmen das. Ich glaub, das ist am besten.
Können wir die Kabel ja trotzdem nehmen. Ich glaub, das ist am besten. Guck mal, wir machen es einfach so. Ich löte den ganzen Kram hier dran, wie es sein muss.
Und dann schneide ich den Kram einfach ab. Das lässt sich ja mit einem Seidenschneider wahrscheinlich easy... äh, Leute, ich hab sowas noch nie geschnitten.
Macht man das mit einem Seitenschneider oder eher mit einer Säge? Wie schneidet man da was ab, gescheit, bei so Teilen? Säge? Ich hab keine Säge für sowas.
Mit einer Küchenschere? Ernsthaft? Ist das weich? Ich hol mal kurz... ich hol mal kurz einen Seitenschneider. Ich muss mal aus... ich knips mal rein.
Nein.
Der Knipschamp ist am Start. So, ich knips jetzt einfach mal... ich knips jetzt einfach mal hier was rein. Geht das so?
Ne, keine Chance, Leute. Das kriegst du nicht ab. Ich hab... ich hab ein Teppichmesser. Mit einem Teppichmesser? Mit einem Teppichmesser vielleicht?
Teppichmesser?
Cuttermesser und Brecht. Exzellent die Idee.
Der Zerteilungschamp ist am Start. So, mal gucken, wie das geht. Ich hab das noch nie gemacht. Ich leg das mal irgendwo drauf. Und jetzt? Und jetzt? Ich hab keinen Plan. Ich hab echt...
Einfach... einfach so und dann hier dran? Warte mal. Gleich ist... gleich ist ein Plutonschamp. Alter, das kann man doch nicht schneiden.
What the fuck, Alter? Das ist brutal. Das ist brutal hart. Wie soll man... Nee, im Leben nicht. Vergiss es. Anritzen und brechen. Also quasi... quasi so in der Richtung hier, oder was?
Ey, nee, im Leben nicht. Im Leben... im Leben nicht.
Okay, das könnte... Leute, das könnte klappen.
Muss man nur gerade machen.
Mal hier.
So, und jetzt hole ich meine Zange und breche dran rum, oder wie? Ob das jetzt funktioniert?
Keck, wait. Ich mach hier wieder Dinger, die schwappen. Was ist das hier? Dreck. Dinger, die schwappen, dann mach ich...
Aber deswegen machen wir ja Stream. Deswegen machen wir ja Stream. So, probieren wir mal. Und jetzt? Einfach?
Hä? Hä? Wollen wir mal den hier? Warte mal, machen wir mal so rum. Halten das lieber damit fest und brechen damit. Wieso? Keck, wait, wait, wait. Alter, das funktioniert ja richtig gut.
Das funktioniert ja richtig gut. Hätte ich nicht gedacht. Chat, chat, big brain. Jeder Sub hat sich gelohnt hier. Da hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das funktioniert.
Übrigens wisst ihr was mir gerade einfällt? Ich glaube das reicht sogar für das was wir brauchen. Ich hab das eigentlich nur aus Spaß und Freude abgeschnitten, weil ich gucken wollte wie man das abschneiden kann.
Aber das reicht für unsere Zwecke. Ich mein wir brauchen 5x Ground und 5x 3,3 Volt. Das reicht ja sogar. Da haben wir so 2 Dinge und ein gutes.
Das ist eigentlich nicht schlecht. Ok, ok. Das ist, das entwickelt sich anders als ich mir das ausgemalt hab vor dem Stream. Aber guck mal und hier brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht viel Platz. Das passt ja einfach easy in die Eck.
So, das heißt wir können jetzt eigentlich, kann man den Kram irgendwie so reinstecken hier? Ach guck mal das passt ja sogar. Vom Abstand her. Also wie macht man das jetzt am besten?
Guck mal wir haben ja theoretisch sogar 3. Jetzt mal vorne, ich benutze diesen Kram normalerweise nicht. Aber könnte man jetzt nicht, du hättest einfach das Kabel an die Stiftleiste gelöhnt, ja wahrscheinlich wäre das echt das einfachste gewesen.
Könnte man jetzt nicht einfach hier unten das irgendwie hier jetzt dranlöten den Kram und dann hätte, ach Moment das ist ja nicht durchgängig das muss man ja von Hand weiter verlängern.
Das ist ja dann aber auch doof. Weil bei den Predboards geht das ja unten durch. Die Dinger sind ja überhaupt nicht verbunden miteinander.
Jetzt ist, ich bin jetzt echt am überlegen. Vielleicht ist die Leiste doch die schönere Variante. Dass man, wir müssen uns jetzt entscheiden für irgendwas. Irgendwo müssen wir jetzt mal anfangen. Wo hab ich denn?
Ich weiß gar nicht wo ich die Leiste hingelegt habe. Hier irgendwo so. Hier.
Okay. Also wie macht man das jetzt am besten dran? Also was wir von der Idee her brauchen wäre ja ich schließe es mal an, dass ich mir das besser vorstellen kann.
Also was wir brauchen ist ja, ich mach den Kram mal kurz hier oben rein. So gehst mal weg. Piss die Schalte. So also was wir brauchen von der Idee her ist ja quasi.
Hm. Ich hab die falschen Kabels. Hatte ich ja nicht eben so ein, dass wir bräuchten hier quasi. Aber ich kann, ne ne Moment ich machs ja nicht mit denen. Das wäre ja bescheuert.
Also das da. Für was, für was verwendet man eigentlich die Dinger hier vorne? Diese Pads die, die so dicker sind als der Rest. Weil verbunden ist der Kram ja nicht. Kann man das als Kontakt irgendwie verwenden?
So. Hm. Ich weiß nicht. Ich hol mal kurz den, den Lötchamp. Bisschen Platz machen. ganzen Krams dahin legen.
So. Mal gucken, dass ich alle Sensoren am Start hab. Wie dick sind denn eigentlich diese Kabels hier? Die sind halt echt furztdünn. Mal gucken ob das der, mal gucken ob das der abisoliert Champ überhaupt abisolieren kann.
Kurz gucken. Wartet mal. Jetzt mal ein Stückchen abschnibbeln. Kann der das? Weil die sind wirklich ganz schön furzig. Ja geht. Geht.
Funktioniert. Ok alles gut. Exzellent. Alles klar gut. Dann holen wir mal den Lötchkorb raus und machen mal ne Runde. Heute früher feiern nicht. Arbeit Montags dann nicht.
Ok mir fällts echt immer noch schwer. Bisschen schwer mir das jetzt in Action vorzustellen. Wie ich das mit dem, wie ich das mit diesem Ding machen soll. Ich mein ernsthaft. Wisst ihr was? Scheiß drauf. Ich mach das unten dran und gut ist.
Es ist doch viel besser. Da muss ich nicht mit dieser komischen Leiste hier rumwursten und so. Wir können es ja immer noch ausbrechen. Ich löte das einfach hier unten dran und gut ist.
So. Also. Das heißt wir brauchen jetzt erstmal den Anschluss fürs Netzteil. Haben wir hier genug? Wie viel haben wir hier? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. Ok das reicht wunderbar. For future use genug übrig.
Wie viele Stunden hast du in der Woche? 30 glaube ich. Umrecht dieses Brillensymbol. Das ist von dem Übertragungsding. Manchmal ist es da und manchmal geht es weg. Ich check es nicht so genau warum das manchmal da ist.
So. Ich muss mal kurz Platz machen. Ich muss den Lötstellen holen. Ich muss hier ein bisschen aufräumen. Den brauchen wir. So.
Dann nehmen wir. Komm wir sind mal ordentlich. Wir nehmen den hier für 3,3 Volt oder beziehungsweise für die 12 Volt Input. Leute. Die Kabel reichen doch wahrscheinlich dicke oder? Ich meine das sind 12 Volt mit irgendwie ein paar milliampere.
Da aber. Ich meine ich könnte auch nur ein bisschen dickere nehmen für den Input. Schadet wahrscheinlich nicht. So. Ich hole jetzt erstmal. Ich hole jetzt erstmal den Lötkolben.
Zack. Jetzt muss ich mal das Handtuch um den Hals weg machen. Auch wenn der Hals dann kalt wird. So. Lötzchen am Start. Lötkolben. Und wo ist die Lötstation auf? Komm raus.
So. Ich hab ja extra noch so einen Abzug aber auf den scheißen wir jetzt mal. So. Das ist immer schwierig im Stream weil ich so wenig Platz hier hab. Müssen wir mal schauen wie wir das am besten jetzt machen.
Excellent Lötchamp. So. Machen wir mal das Netzteil hier kurz raus. Machen den hier dran.
Okay. Mein Busy Busy Platz ist hier ja. Wir müssen das nur mal aus dem Weg. Aus dem Weg machen hier. Zack. So. Nicht nicht nicht all zu viel Platz hier. Wie gesagt das Ding hier ist nicht so groß.
So. Jetzt haben wir den. Den müssen wir jetzt verbinden mit. Nee. Erstmal machen wir hier so eine Leiste. So. Leiste. So. Das ist. Ich glaube Leute. Habt ihr überhaupt eine Ahnung? Ich glaube das Außen ist. Das da ist glaube ich Minus. Und das ist Plus in der Mitte.
Mitte Plus. Außen Minus. Wenn ich jetzt nicht. Ich bin mir da relativ sicher. So zu 95%. Nee. Handtuch ist besser als Schal. Schal. Sucked. Alter. Sucked. Huge Sucked.
Machen wir mal hier ein paar Dinger ab.
Wo habe ich das Abisoliert Champ hin? Hier.
So. Ist die Lötestation an? Nope. Machen wir sie mal an. Ich hoffe ihr seht was. Ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen weiter hinter.
Wie viel ist standardmäßig eingestellt? Sieht man irgendwie Temperatur oder so? So. Ich glaube man sieht. Sieht man Temperatur? Ja ne.
300 irgendwas. Ist viel zu warm. Das wird gleich ein bisschen kälter. Okay. Was auf dem Abisoliert Champ drauf steht soll ich dir zeigen? Hier.
Das ist eine Yokari Super 4 Plus. Kannst du mal einen Reflink kaufen? Nee ich hab keinen Reflink dafür. Aber ich sollte Reflinks machen.
Pass auf das Display auf. Oh. Ah ne passt schon. Ich muss ja hier mal auf mein Kabel hier aufpassen. Okay. Das ist alles sehr wackelig.
Alter ist das sackig. Jetzt wird es schwierig. Ich muss den heißen Lötkol mir irgendwie durchfummeln. Exzellent. How to not. Aber sehr schön. Gut. Also.
Löten wir den Kram erstmal dran. Wir können jetzt ja einfach messen was Plus und Minus ist klar. Ich würde sagen wir machen das jetzt erstmal hier dran. Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlimm. Das kriege ich danach auch wieder direkt ins Gehäuse.
Ja auf please. What the fuck. Hallo. Löt Champ. Champ dich. Sehr gut. Alles klar. Kunst. Okay.
Gut dann machen wir jetzt erstmal hier ein bisschen was ans Kabel dran. Was für mich jetzt gar nicht so einfach ist, weil ich das vom Winkel her nicht gut sehe.
Und ich sollte ich habe so ein paar Klammern, wo man so Sachen gut gut festhalten kann. Aber da habe ich jetzt keinen Platz für.
Ich muss den Kram irgendwie festhalten. Okay. Exzellent. Exzellent. So dann machen wir das mal an den Stecker dran. Also.
Was hatten wir gesagt? Das da. Gibt es irgendwelche Conventions? Blau ist Plus. Weiß ist Minus. Nee oder? Glaub nicht. Gibt es da irgendwas?
Hast du immer noch was mit Terraform gemacht? Ja. Hab ich. Terraform ist nice. Also was ich mit Terraform. Alter komm mal her.
Ich habe mit Terraform beispielsweise ein bisschen Hetzner Geschichten rumgespielt. Auf der Arbeit haben wir das auch.
Wenn du kein Rot und Schwarz hast. Nee. Von dem bisschen dickeren Kabel leider nicht.
Schieben wir das mal hier rein. Ich brauche was zum festhalten. Das sackt.
So. Irgendwie so, dass das jetzt hält. Gucken, weil das Problem ist. Ich kriege das nicht richtig dran.
Okay. Wir machen jetzt Trick 17. Ich mache jetzt einfach hier ein bisschen was dran.
Und ich hoffe das hält jetzt. Ich hoffe das hält jetzt einfach, wenn ich das hier.
Sieht doch ganz okay aus. Sieht doch ganz brauchbar aus.
Du brauchst einen Sackchamp ja. Was heißt das Ding jetzt heiß? Nee. Wobei. Das Ding ist so fett. Ist nicht heiß.
Guck mal. Ist eigentlich ganz gut geworden. Hallo. Campchamp. Guck mal. Eigentlich recht nice. Pass.
Eingebaute. Alligator. Was? Ach so. Ja ich habe so ein Ding. Ich habe welche, die kann man neben an den Tisch dran klemmen. Und dann hat man so Teile, die man hier rein macht. Das habe ich jetzt gerade keinen Platz für.
So. Dann machen wir den Kram da unten noch dran. Das machen wir auf die Unterseite, dass ich den Kram nicht irgendwie zusammen kriege oder so. Dann Kurzschlusschamp mache.
Ich habe es übrigens ein bisschen zu lang isoliert. Ich hätte das eigentlich deutlich kürzer abisolieren müssen. Ich bin jetzt aber zu faul da irgendwie einen Schrumpfschlauch oder so drüber zu machen.
Das testen wir jetzt mal.
So. Gucken wir mal ob wir das jetzt irgendwie da dran kriegen. Kurz davor setzen.
Okay. Nice. Ach so. Ich habe es an der falschen Seite gemacht. Loll. Ich muss es da unten eigentlich machen.
Andere Seite.
Nice.
Das hält ist aber nicht schön.
Schön ist was anderes.
Ich muss es gerade mal irgendwie so machen, dass es hält. Vor allem, dass ich gescheit hinkomme.
Mist. Jetzt ist es ab. Ah fuck.
Jetzt ist es okay. Ja, jetzt ist es gut. Okay, jetzt hält es. Alles klar.
Liebst doch vom abisolierten Stück was ab. Das hätte ich machen können, bevor ich es dran gelötet hätte. Ja, Loll. Das stimmt.
Ja, das passt schon. Da wird nichts zusammen kommen. Ja, das ist eigentlich. Da. Ja, ne. Ob das passt. So. Also jetzt messen wir das erste Mal. Ich stelle es mal. Ich mache das hier mal kurz weg.
Ich mache es mal aus. So, jetzt messen wir das gerade nochmal. Schnell mal gucken. Was ist da Plus und Minus? Ich glaube, das Außen ist Minus und das Mitte ist Plus. Aber ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher.
Ja, machen wir mal. Probieren wir mal aus. Also ich glaube, es ist so rum.
Dann hast du eine Hand fürs Leben. Ja, das gibt bestimmt viele, viele Taktiken. Wo ist das Netzteil? Ah, ich habe es auf die Erde gelegt, Loll.
Also ich muss den Lüttschamp raus machen, das habe ich nicht genug. So. Also schauen wir mal. Was haben wir da? Ja, passt. Also.
Okay, ja, ja, passt. Also das Blaue ist Plus und das Weiße ist Minus. Alles klar. Sehr schön. Weil ansonsten wäre es umgedreht.
Sonst wird da, wenn ich es andersrum dranhalte, es steht dann. Guckt, wenn ich das so rum dranhalte, dann steht da Minus. Weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt erkennt.
Deswegen weiß ich, dass es so rumrichtig ist. Alles klar. Exquisite. Wow. Ja, ja, ist doch gut.
Wieso fliegt, wieso fliegt nichts in die Luft? Ja, weil ich keine Ahnung habe. Du weißt doch, die Leute, die keinen Plan haben, bei denen läuft es meistens gut.
Und bei denen, die Ahnung haben, guckt die Elektro-Boom an, flögen die Sachen in die Luft. Wobei bei ihm das hält auch zu 99%.
Eine Mischung aus Fake, hohe Schmerztoleranz und teilweise auch irgendwelche Effekte sind. Okay, so haben wir das dran gemacht.
Weiter geht's. Jetzt können wir das an den Spannungswandler dran machen, würde ich sagen. Okay, machen wir das mal wieder ab und machen den Loot-Champ dran.
Also mal kurz in mich gehen. Das ergibt keinen Sinn. Das da muss ich jetzt das erste Mal hier dran löten, dass ich genug Ground-Pins habe.
Da kommen wir nicht drum herum. So, wieviel Ground-Pins habe ich gesagt brauche ich? Hier. Display, also eins, zwei, drei, vier. Und wo habe ich jetzt den fünf?
Brauche ich eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Ground-Pins. Das bedeutet, ich habe hier eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf. Wisst ihr was, ich mache einfach das ganze Ding dran und gut ist.
Ich kann es ja nachher immer noch abschneiden. Bevor ich da jetzt zu wenig dran mache, ist ein bisschen doof.
Genau, dann müssen wir das eine Runde weiter nochmal mehr abisoliert champen. Hier kann man nämlich ein bisschen die Länge einstellen.
Wir brauchen so. Das kommt sogar ziemlich gut hin.
Guck mal, guck doch mal wie gut das passt, seht ihr das? Huge Pass-Champ. Bis auf den letzten Pin, aber der juckt mich nicht.
Ja, also Elektro-Boom, der müsste eigentlich noch 50 mal mehr sagen, nicht nachmachen, weil die Dinger sind echt ne Ione.
Okay, wir machen das dann so rein, das kann man dann hier hochkant machen. Machen wir das jetzt nach innen oder nach außen, wobei das können wir drehen, das ist erstmal egal.
Ein Stückchen mehr müsste ich noch abisolieren, falls das der abisoliert Champ noch mitmacht.
Ein Stückchen mehr, da kriege ich nämlich alle Pins dran. Guck mal, seht ihr wie nice das passt hier? Massive.
Jetzt kriege ich alle Pins dran, so ist das doch nice. Erkennt man das überhaupt gerade? Ja, es flimmert ein bisschen, aber es ist blau auf blau, sakt.
Aber ich habe eigentlich höchste Auflösung dran. Oder nicht?
Das hat man, Leute, die Sachen hier konnte man sonst auch nicht sonderlich hundertprozentig scharf erkannt, oder?
Weil ich glaube, ich habe schon volle Auflösung, die geht. Man kann sich das doch irgendwie sogar anzeigen lassen.
Steuerelemente, konnte man sich nicht irgendwie noch Bild oder irgendwelche Infos anzeigen lassen? Vielleicht nicht.
Einer OBS-Ninja-House, ja. So, dann machen wir das jetzt erstmal schnell dran hier.
Kurz schauen, dass man den Kram so hinlegen, dass ich den ordentlich dranlöten kann. Guck mal, so ist das doch exellent. Kann ich das hier nämlich halten?
Probieren wir das mal aus, probieren wir das doch mal aus. Ach so, ha. Weiß nicht, seht ihr das noch? Hoff mal.
Okay, ich mach das von oben, da seh ich mehr. Ich seh nix, das sackt mega.
Ich seh nix. Das ist ja kacke, ey. Wie mach ich denn das jetzt gescheit? Ich muss das irgendwie, ha, ich hab die Idee Leute, massive Idee, guck mal.
Ich steck das einfach hier rein und dann kann ich das hier dranlöten und mit der einen Hand halten. Ich glaub das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Erstmal n bisschen Zeug drauf. Ich hab in nem Video gesehen, dass es besser ist, man hält den Lötkolben unten dran anstatt oben dran.
Keine Ahnung ob das stimmt, da was dran ist. Aber ich mein, YouTube würde uns nie anlügen mit sowas. YouTube sagt prinzipiell immer die Wahrheit, das ist ja klar.
Kann das mal reingehen, please? Elevenhead, ja, richtig, Elevenhead YouTube. So, und jetzt muss ich den Kram irgendwie. Fuck, wie krieg ich denn das jetzt richtig dran?
Vielleicht brauch ich das gar nicht. Ich hab keine freie Hand, das sackt.
Huge sack. Ich bräuchte irgendwas, wo ich den Kram mit festhalten kann. Irgendeine Klammer oder so.
Oder, das ist was wir machen, ich mach das einfach an der vorderen Seite schon fest. Ich machs an der vorderen Seite fest.
Man sollte das einschalten. Jetzt fällt es auch noch da raus, ey. Was ein Gefudel, Alter. Wie viele Hände hast du, ich hab eindeutig zu wenige Hände.
Weil du musst ja schon ein bisschen dagegen drücken, dass es hält. Sack, Alter. Massive sack.
Come on. Jetzt hab ich das hier durchgeschoben, ey. Schäpp.
Wieder grad. Wir machen das jetzt die Brute Force Taktik. Das ist echt mega sackig, Alter. Ich brauch da irgendwas zum draufsch...
Ich brauch irgendwas zum festhalten. Was hab ich denn hier, komm. Exzellent. Kannste irgendwie mit der Zange machen oder so.
So. Eigentlich was ein Gefudel.
Ich hab jetzt eigentlich auf beide Seiten was drauf gemacht in der Hoffnung, dass es hält. Aber es hält nicht.
Das ist eigentlich giftig. Das ist eigentlich giftig, wenn man das einatmet, Leute. Zumindest ist es nicht gut.
Ohne Scheiß ist das eines der ekligsten Sachen, die ich je gelötet hab. Was ist das für eine Scheiße. Das hält einfach nicht.
Ey, guck mal. Das sah so aus, als wäre es fest. Nee, ist gesund, dachte ich mir. Nee, das ist nicht bleifrei.
Flutscht besser. Wie krieg ich den Kack denn jetzt zu... Kann das doch irgendwie zusammenhalten oder so.
Ich mein, mit der Hand ist das Problem. Das wird heiß. Ja, es wird heiß. Das kannst du nicht machen.
Ich brauch mal Zeug zum Festhalten. Wie krieg ich das jetzt hin? Das ist doch machbar irgendwie.
Okay. So, jetzt mal gucken, ob das jetzt wenigstens hält. Das hält? Warum hält denn das nicht? Ich hab doch da jetzt massig drauf gemacht.
Alter. So, jetzt aber. Jetzt sollte es fest sein. So, jetzt kann ich den Kram nämlich bei den anderen festmachen.
Wenn ich ja was sehen würde, Alter.
Das ist der mega Sack, ey. Was für eine bescheuerte Idee bin ich gekommen, dass das eine gute Idee ist. Was für eine beknackte Idee, Alter.
Ich mein, das ist jetzt wenigstens vorne fest. Wie wird der Zähler ausgelesen? Der Zähler wird ausgelesen.
Einmal mit einem Sensor für eine LED, die blinkt. Und einmal mit einem Sensor, die er kennen kann, wenn der Strich durchläuft am Zähler. Er kann beides.
Komm, mit Mario Kart Musik geht das jetzt. Easy. Easy as fuck.
Eine Sache, die immer geht, ist das erste und das letzte zuerst festmachen.
Ich glaube, es ist fest. Das ist eines der beschissensten Sachen, die ich je zusammengelöhlt habe. Meine Fresse, ist das scheiße.
Also die Idee war nicht so gut. Wir versuchen das jetzt einfach mal in Lütz hin zu ersaufen, dass das irgendwie hält.
Zumindest müssen wir uns um Kurzschlüsse keine Gedanken machen hier, weil das ist alles am gleichen dran.
Nee, mit OCR machen wir das nicht. OCR funktioniert nicht gescheit, habe ich schon ausprobiert. Kann man machen, aber nicht. Ist nicht so richtig gut.
Das geht nur gut, wenn man Platz hat im Schrank. Alter, ich habe es wieder abgemacht. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr. Das ist so beschissen, ohne dass ich das was habe, was es festhalten kann.
Mega, Alter. Schau mal an, das ist doch voll beschissen. So ein Kack. Ich muss den Kram irgendwie festgehalten kriegen. Wie mache ich das denn jetzt? Ich habe keinen Platz.
He doesn't know, he lacks critical information. Kann man das irgendwie so zusammendrücken mit der Zange?
An manchen ist es ja dran. Okay, ich habe eine Idee. Das muss ich auf der anderen Seite auch noch machen.
Okay, ich probiere das jetzt noch einmal und dann habe ich keinen Bock mehr. Das wird doch im Leben nichts.
Das ist mega beschissen. Das funktioniert nicht. Das war echt eine dumme Idee von mir, das so zu machen. Das war eine mega bescheuerte Idee.
Das klappt einfach nicht. Ich hätte das doch mit dem Board machen sollen. Da hätte ich jetzt einfach schon drüber machen können und gut wäre.
Ich habe mir das so viel einfacher vorgestellt. Guck mal, das funktioniert. Ich kriege das einfach nicht gleichmäßig dran, weil es die ganze Zeit rumwackelt.
Ich muss einfach nur fest genug draufdrücken.
Das geht wieder ab zwischendurch, weil es die Zeit nicht richtig zusammenhält. Ich habe nichts, wie ich es zusammenhalten kann, gescheit.
Ich will es jetzt aber auch nicht anders machen. Ich habe da schon massig. Ich muss mal ein bisschen Fenster aufmachen.
So einfach ist das gar nicht. Hier mal eine klorische Idee.
Normalerweise muss ich hier draufdrücken.
Okay Max, das war eine beschissen Idee. Das funktioniert nicht.
Eine mega kacke Idee. Mega bescheuert. Vielleicht per Zickzack. Ich weiß nicht. Ich meine, das hält ja, aber halt nicht überall fest.
Wenn du es zu lange heiß machst, fällt es woanders ab.
Ich glaube, es ist jetzt überall dran, aber das ist beschissen. Das ist echt keine gute Idee.
Das Zeug ist halt nicht umsonst dafür gedacht. Ich habe es jetzt dran, aber so etwas ekliges kannst du vergessen. Guckt euch das mal an.
Warum nicht dann doch die Lochraste weiter? Ja doch, jetzt könnte ich die Lochraste.
Ich muss einfach ein bisschen mehr Lötzchen drauf machen, dann geht es wieder gut aus.
Man muss es auf jeden Fall von oben machen, dann kann man draufdrücken. Das habe ich schon mal kapiert.
Aha.
Okay, so langsam sieht es ganz gut aus.
Einfach noch mehr Lötzchen drauf.
Leute, wir haben es. Wir haben es. Victory, Alter. Wir haben es. Guckt es euch mal an.
Guckt es euch mal an hier. Wie vom Profi. Easy. Nur mit dem Problem ist, beim ersten ist das Lötzchen nicht am Kabel dran.
Das müssen wir noch kurz fixen. Bis ich einfach ein bisschen draufdrücke.
Und jetzt von der anderen Seite nochmal ordentlich Lötzchen draufklatschen. Ich glaube es ist dran.
Okay, so bleibt es jetzt. Easy. So ist gut. Perfekt. Einfach möglichst viel Lötzchen draufklatschen.
Top. Top. Top. Exquisite. Exquisite. Jetzt kurz Fenster kippen.
So und jetzt die andere Seite. Das war es dann nicht. Die andere Seite muss ja auch noch.
Ich habe hier noch ein paar Pinn. Header. Ich gebe dir Header, Alter. Header. Header, Mann. Header.
Hier, komm raus. Wo sind die Header? Header. Guckt mal, das ist noch mehr. Brauchen wir aber nicht.
Also wie viel brauchen wir da? Ich mache das gleiche. Wo habe ich? Weiß was ich jetzt mit dem Messer mache.
Egal, ich habe keinen Bock Seitenschneider drüber zu holen. Wie viel haben wir da?
Drei. Exzellent. Ich muss bloß aufpassen, dass es nicht runterfällt. Wenn es nämlich runterfällt, dann geht es in den Fuß und das ist schmerzhaft.
So. Alter, habe ich das Ding hier. Ist ja die halbe Rolle Lötzchen drauf. Okay. Abisoliert Champ.
Passt. Deswegen mag ich die Abisoliert Zange. Damit ist man da. Das ist so schön reproduzierbar immer.
So haben wir jetzt was aus dem ersten gelernt. Mal gucken, ob wir es jetzt besser hinkriegen.
Also was ich aus dem ersten definitiv gelernt habe ist. Viel hilft viel.
Viel hilft viel. Einfach viel Lötzchen drauf. Wickelt den Draht um die Pins. Ja, das können die nicht machen.
Da habe ich aber nicht genug Draht für. Aber das ist eine gute Idee.
Habe ich nicht gesagt, ich muss es von oben machen, weil es dann besser geht.
Es geht doch im Leben nicht besser. Aber ich weiß auch warum, weil das ganz Schäpp ist. Guck mal. Ich wollte erst mal ein bisschen gerade machen.
Jetzt machen wir das hintere zuerst fest. Es ist halt echt nicht der Weiß als letzter Schluss.
Ich habe auch noch diesen kleinen Scheiß hier. Das funktioniert mal.
Wie habe ich das am Anfang hingekriegt? Ich musste die ersten irgendwie festkriegen.
Das habe ich doch irgendwie mit der Zange gemacht oder so.
Das hat irgendwie so festgehalten. Das ist doch kacke. Ich kann da nichts weben. Der ist da kurz dafür.
Ich werde es so machen wie auf der Seite. Ich werde es jetzt ertränken in Lötzchen, bis es hält.
Beste Idee. Einfach so viel Lötzchen drauf machen, dass es gar nichts mehr anderes kann, außer festzuhalten.
Das ist aber schepp. Sackt. Das mache ich nie wieder, Leute. So eine Kacktaktik.
Chat, wer hat sich das ausgedacht von euch nochmal?
Moment, warte mal. Ich muss das gar nicht festlöten. Fällt mir gerade auf.
Ich muss das gar nicht festlöten. Ich muss das später festlöten. Jetzt hätte ich es fast festgelötet und verkehrt gemacht.
Ich muss doch erst mal den hier... Okay, das war bescheuer. Der hier ist richtig. Der ist richtig. Aber der hier ist nicht richtig.
Weil der da, das ist 12 Volt innen. Jetzt hätte ich es fast gerippt. Der muss da dran. Also kann ich mal abschneiden ein bisschen.
Der muss nämlich hier an den V-Innen ran.
Guck mal, ob das...
Warte mal, wie mache ich denn das jetzt? Lass mal überlegen, dass das vielleicht dann besser funzt.
Wenn ich das jetzt hier dran löte, dann muss ich von hier dann rüber eins machen für Ground. Das ist okay.
Und in der Mitte mache ich ein Kabel drauf.
Jetzt wird der Wandler gegrillt. Kannst nicht alles haben. Easy, easy.
Ich mache erst mal ein bisschen... Das sollte doch aushalten. Ich mache erst mal ein bisschen hier dran.
Na, ordentlich drauf. Jetzt...
Hier ordentlich drauf. Jetzt hält es hoffentlich von alleine.
Den können wir jetzt festhalten hinten.
Das hält nicht, warum nicht?
Sehr gut.
Hält. Hält sogar relativ gut.
So. Exquisite.
Das heißt, den machen wir jetzt am besten...
Den machen wir jetzt am besten, den Kram hier. Also...
Hier haben wir unsere Ground Pins. Da haben wir den... Hier muss auf jeden Fall noch mal ein Ground dran.
Das könnte ich mit so einem Draht hier verbinden oder... Nee, wir machen das mit so einem hier. Das ist natürlich dann schon sinnvoller.
Wenn wir den Kram ja schon da haben...
Gehen wir hier rüber. Irgendwie so.
Abisoniert Champ wieder am Werk.
Zack.
So, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten? Ich würde sagen, wir könnten das doch eigentlich hier direkt rüber machen, oder?
Von da... Von da nach da.
Was ist denn das für ein riesen Bauteil? Das ist ein 12 Volt zu 3,3 Volt Spannungswandler für den Controller.
Also, dann machen wir das mal dran. Erst mal kurz ein bisschen sauber machen.
Der muss weg.
Machen wir erstmal da ein bisschen Lötzchen dran.
Auf. Wird warm.
Exzellent.
Machen wir das auch drunter. Das habe ich letztens im Video gesehen. War eigentlich richtig big brain.
Habe gesagt, man soll den Lötkolben von unten dran halten. Dann wird es... Dann klappt das besser.
Wir wissen ja, YouTube kann man prinzipiell alles glauben, was das...
angeht. Und das funktioniert ja auch, also...
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten? Sodass ich in die Mitte nicht drankomme?
Runtermachen.
Easy. Hält. Gut. Nice. So, und das jetzt auf die andere Seite.
Irgendwie hier noch dran. Und dann passt das eigentlich ganz okay.
Wobei das eigentlich ziemlich bescheuert ist. Da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich auch was von den dickeren Kabel nehmen sollen.
Naja, egal. Ich sagte, paar Milli Ampere da.
Noch mal kurz. Lötzchen dran. So und jetzt aufpassen, dass ich den Scheiß dann wieder abmache.
Aber da ist so viel Lötzchen dran auf der Seite. Das müsste... Das müsste eigentlich halten, ohne dass ich da irgendwas mache.
Hoffe ich mal.
Wartet mal, wartet mal. Ich hab doch... Jetzt kann ich doch meine Zange nehmen. Jetzt kann ich doch meine Zange nehmen dafür.
So, jetzt kann ich nämlich einfach mit dem Lötkolben truffen und ich hoffe, das reicht dann.
Oder auch nicht. Warum nicht? Warum will ich das nicht anlöten? Kein Bock.
Soll doch eigentlich easy dran gehen jetzt.
Ich hab keinen dritten Arm mehr. Ich hab eine Zange.
Ich hab vor allem keinen Platz. Das ist mein hauptsächliches Problem hier.
Das funktioniert nicht richtig. Warte mal, das machen wir jetzt so. Aufpassen. Muss schnell sein, dass ich mir den Finger verbrenne.
Easy ist dran. Zack. Gut, passt. So, ich hoffe, wir haben das jetzt richtig gemacht.
Okay, nice. Ich hab eigentlich gedacht, es geht ein bisschen schneller, aber so ist das halt.
Ja, der Lötkolben steht schon da hinten rum. Gut.
So, zum Einsetzen muss ich wahrscheinlich den Kram hier unten noch mal ablöten, aber scheiß drauf.
Okay, so, jetzt kann ich den Kram anschließen. Oh nee, jetzt kommt noch eine unangenehme Geschichte.
Hat doch hier irgendwo so ein Orange, ne? Das machen wir jetzt mal hiermit.
Ich will das nämlich nicht irgendwie im Zweifelsfall, im einfachen das Gefecht kurz schließen. Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wir können gerade noch mal gucken, ob es prinzipiell funktioniert, was ich da zusammen gewusstet hab.
Also, wenn das jetzt alles funktioniert, dann sollten da jetzt 3,3 Volt drauf sein für den Controller.
Gucken wir mal. Zack. Und dann seh ich auch gleich, ob es richtig angeschlossen hat.
Netzteil, please. Und dann können wir gucken.
Also Leute, mein ich, ob das funktioniert? Müsste eigentlich, müsste eigentlich klappen.
So, Spannungswander ist an. 3,3 Volt, excellent. Okay, der Scheiß funktioniert.
Wir können auch gleich mal messen, ob ich alles ordentlich angeschlossen hab.
So, wir gucken mal kurz, ob ich alles richtig angeschlossen hab. Also, der da will, der da will auch, der da auch, der da auch, der da auch, der auch, der auch und der auch.
Na, immerhin, immerhin den Kram wenigstens ordentlich angeschlossen.
Gut, sehr gut, das funst, Poggers. Ich hab so ne Scheiß-Haltung, ich tu jetzt den Rücken weh, weil ich hier so kacke über dem Ding hänge.
So, okay, und den Kram müsste ich jetzt ja von der Theorie her, hätte ich da mal doch einen Schrumpfschlauch drüber gemacht, aber na gut, ist es halt.
Hätte ich ja nämlich einen Schrumpfschlauch drüber gemacht, da könnte ich jetzt hier einfach eins von diesen kleinen Dingern nehmen.
Na, und das passt nämlich nicht, das sackt. Wie mach ich denn das jetzt gescheit?
Weil ich, ich hab Schiss, dass das sich hier irgendwie kurz schließt, wenn ich hier in der Mitte unisoliert.
Na, guckt mal. Na, in der Mitte ist ja mein Output. Und da ist nichts isoliert oder sonst was.
Mit Heißkleber isolieren, das ist ne echt gute Idee. Heißkleber geht immer. Heißkleber, ja, das ist ne...
Heißkleber geht immer. Das ist ne Top-Idee. Okay, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal einen roten.
Stück von den roten Kabels. So, bevor wir das anschließen, ich machs erst hier dran, weil ich glaube, das ist viel einfacher dran zu machen, wenn es nicht so rum hängt.
So, abisoliert, Champ. Volle Länge. Off. Oh, iiih. Jetzt, Leute, jetzt kann ich das machen, was ihr gesagt habt.
Ich kann die Kabel drum herum machen. Hey, das ist ne gute Idee, das mach ich jetzt. Das mach ich jetzt. Ich hör mal auf den Chat. Guck mal, wir können das so machen irgendwie.
Das funktioniert. Das ist irgendwie so drum herum, so drum herum Wurst oder so. Das könnte funktionieren.
Nein, man könnte... Ich mein, sag mal, wie dick sind denn diese Kabel? Ist das ungefähr das Gleiche? Was meint ihr, was ist dicker innen drinne?
Ist das ungefähr das Gleiche, die beiden? Ich würd mal sagen, das Jumperkabel ist ne ganze Ecke dünner, ne? Ich glaub, da kann man jetzt allzu viel machen.
Ich schneide mal so ein Ding auf hier. Keine Ahnung, wie das da drinne aussieht.
Ja, guck mal, das sind nur ein paar, das sind ein paar Drehchen, das sind ein paar, das sind deutliche mehr.
Mach ich lieber ne Runde Heißkleber oder so drauf. Ja, guck mal, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funkt. Vielleicht krieg ich das hier irgendwie rein in die Mitte.
Ey, das könnte funktionieren. Das könnte klappen.
Wenn man das jetzt, wenn man das dann quasi so festlötet. So irgendwie.
Wenn man einfach volle Pulle Lötzend draufklatscht. Das müsste vielleicht funktionieren. Versuch ist es wert.
Und? Paar Girls.
Das war ne gute Idee.
Ja, einfach, einfach fließen, please. Das hält ja schon mal. Das heißt, jetzt können wir das einfach da drauf stecken.
Viel Lötzend ist immer, ja muss. Viel hilft viel. Oh, what the fuck.
Das ist keine gute Idee, das da reinzustecken. Das wird dann ganz schepp. Okay, jetzt ist wieder gerade. Das ist nicht so, nicht agil genug.
Agile, die Agile Agilnis fehlt. Dann machen wir einfach nur noch mehr Lötzend drauf, wenn gut ist.
Aber wenn wir schieben das einfach hier an den Rand, da kann es nicht rutschen.
Ich glaube, wir haben es. Ich glaube, wir haben es mehr oder weniger.
Pest. Einfach noch mehr Lötzend draufhauen, easy.
Einfach, einfach mehr Lötzend draufhauen, easy. Das ist dann kein Ding.
Es wackelt immer noch ein bisschen, aber das klappt schon mal viel besser als das andere.
Ich würde sagen, es ist fest. Viel besser als das andere, Leute. Bei dem anderen habe ich Anfälle gekriegt. Das hier geht jetzt eigentlich, guckt mal.
Geht eigentlich, ging eigentlich direkt fest. Der muss mit mehr Scrum arbeiten. Ja, genau. Overlay. Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, ich mache noch mal kurz hier auf die Seite noch ein bisschen was drauf. Volle Pulle. Agile Champ.
Perfekt. Exzellent. So bleibt es jetzt, fertig. Genug. Sehr schön, sehr schön. Gut.
Und wie bastle ich das da jetzt dran? Also, ich muss das hier in die Mitte dran machen, in der Hoffnung, ich schließe das da nicht kurz.
Ich mache da einfach einen, ich mache da einfach einen Dingsheißkleber drauf, wenn gut ist.
Du musst immer an mich denken, wenn du was von Agile lest. Ja, Agileness ist hier. Muss zur Zeit. Ein absolutes Muss, dass da irgendwo Agil drin steht.
Ohne gibt es nicht mehr. Unagil sein kann man sich heute einmal erlauben.
Es ist ja quasi Agiles, wenn man nicht Agil ist. Wie viel Grad hat mein Kolben? 50 Milliarden Grad.
Gatschi Bass Kolben. Wie kriege ich das da jetzt gescheit dran? Gag weight, Alter.
Ich muss da nur ein bisschen dran machen. Da bräuchte ich eine kleinere Spitze, weil das meistens mache ich die Isolierung von den Kabeln kaputt.
Passt. Passt auch. Jetzt sollte das nämlich eigentlich ganz gut passen. Wisst ihr was? Ich kann es einfach andersrum machen. Kann ich das so rum? So rum?
Nee, das ist doof. Wobei ich. Was jetzt sinnvoller so? Weißte was, Scheiße.
Exzellent.
Sehr gut. Warum sollte man sowas isolieren? Scheiß drauf. Ich mache da einfach ein bisschen Heißkleber drauf nachher.
Jetzt können wir noch mal nachmessen, ob der Kram funktioniert, was wir gemacht haben. Ich weiß nicht, wollen wir mal gucken, was maximale Temperatur ist?
Maximale Temperatur. Also aktuell sind wir bei 300. By the way, warum eigentlich 300? Das ist viel zu warm.
Oder? Das geht doch bestimmt auch. Geht doch bestimmt auch noch. Ach nee, Moment. Ich habe es letztes Mal schon kleiner gestellt. Kann das sein? War das nicht sonst immer sogar 380?
Und es ist voll abgegangen? Okay, wir probieren mal, was ist das Wärmste, was geht. Testen wir mal. Fahren wir mal hoch. 450.
Gucken wir mal. Geht noch. 450 ist Max. FPS 0. Oh, schlechter Witz. So, gehen wir mal runter wieder auf 300. Das reicht.
Oh, jetzt sind wir bei 200. Jetzt sind wir wieder bei 300.
Okay. So, jetzt machen wir den mal raus, weil eigentlich haben wir jetzt erst mal soweit fertig gelötet. Zum Testen kann ich jetzt mit Jumperkabels weiter machen, bevor ich es ins Gehäuse einbaue.
Okay, dann messen wir das noch mal kurz. Ach was, scheiß drauf. Wir messen nix. Schließen einfach an. YOLO, Alter.
Gut, jetzt haben wir hier Dinger. Jetzt können wir den Controller mal anschließen. Wo habe ich schon den Controller? Da.
So, einmal, einmal messe ich das noch, ob da jetzt wirklich 3,3 Volt rauskommt. Ich will es nicht. Ich will es dann wirklich killen, jetzt irgendwie noch einen Controller, habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wir sind dran. Zack. Okay, bisschen abwickeln noch, alles klar. Netzteil. Packweight.
Okay. Also, was, Hammer. 3,3 Volt, easy, funktioniert, alles gut.
Excellent. Oh. Auf, geh ab. Okay, gut, hätten wir. Woop, S incoming, nee, nee. Okay, nice. Also, dann schließen wir doch jetzt mal den Controller an.
Ah, ich kann den Controller gar nicht anschließen, ich hab da gar keine Pins dran. What, Packweight. Ja, das ist jetzt natürlich die nächste Frage, mache ich da Pins dran?
Eigentlich, eigentlich, weiß ich nicht, ob ich da Pins dran mache, weil die nehmen so viel Platz in dem Gehäuse weg. Guck mal, die sind auch total sinnlos, zumal ich ja eh gar keine Jumperkabel dran mache, sondern einfach nur so.
Nee, komm. Zum, zum ausprobieren, ich, ich mache ich mal das Ding jetzt hier dran. Nee, oder, hm.
Ich habe da jetzt eine gute abgeschnittene Jumper dran. Hä?
Nee, komm. Nee, komm. Wir machen jetzt mal zumindest auf der Seite. Da haben wir, komm, für die paar Kabel haben wir genug. Für die paar Kabel haben wir, haben wir genug, das passt.
Das ist so klein, was ich hier gebaut habe, das nimmt kaum, nimmt kaum Platz weg. Das passt. Ich mache da jetzt, ich mache da jetzt, äh, Packweight.
Ich habe noch welche dabei eben. Hallo? Please rauskommen. Doch, hier, da. Kein Sorge, ich habe da noch genug von. Wir machen zumindest mal die Seite für Stromanschluss und so rein.
Ja. Jumperkabel in der Mitte durch, in dein Powerblock einstecken. Wat? Und dann? Nee. Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert, wenn ich die einfach nur reinstecke, oder?
Das habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie ausprobiert, aber in die Kamera gar nicht rein. Das funktioniert doch im Leben, oder?
Die abgeschnittene Seite anlöten, ok, das könnte man tatsächlich machen. Du meinst quasi im Endeffekt sowas hier. Du meinst quasi im Endeffekt sowas hier.
Dass wir das hier anstöpseln und dann abschneiden und hier dranlöten. Ja, das ist tatsächlich gar keine schlechte Idee. Das könnte man machen und so verdoppeln wir auch die Kabels.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, das gefällt mir, das hat was. Da muss ich aber den Lötchamp ja schon wieder dran machen. Oh, meine Güte.
Der Lötchamp muss heute ganz schön leiden.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee, das gefällt mir, das hat was. Ok, schauen wir mal hier ab. Also wie viel Platz? Also für den Kram brauchen wir auf jeden Fall nicht viel Platz.
Wir brauchen jetzt eins für... Wie gut, dass ich hier schon vorhin eins durchgeschnitten habe. Also wir brauchen eins für Ground, für den Controller.
Oh, das passt überhaupt nicht. Doch. Einmal Ground und einmal 3,3 Volt. Ok, mal gucken. Das habe ich so noch nie gemacht, das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Probieren wir mal aus. Von diesen Jumperkabeln habe ich echt genug.
Die Konstruktion ist Pain's Jam, ja. Der Chat ist schuld, wie immer.
Ich glaube ich löte da doch Pins drauf.
Alles klar, dann waren wir mal dran hier. Also wir haben einmal 3,3 Volt und dann brauchen wir hier den für Ground.
Ground fangen wir an. Machen wir hier mal ab. Waren wir auch schon kurz, dass da nichts passiert.
Ja.
Auch nicht wirklich durchdacht, nur ich habe null durchdacht, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ich habe gedacht wir machen das jetzt einfach mal was.
Und ich muss sagen, lustigerweise, ich habe viel weniger Kopfweh als am Anfang. Was eigentlich witzig ist, weil normalerweise ist das Pain's Jam ein bisschen, wenn man so Kleinkram macht.
Aber das liegt daran, dass ich die ganze Zeit hier aufstehen bin, hinsetzen bin, Chat gucken bin.
Das setzt an. Ja. Das hat es also aus dem Grund hat es schon mal gelohnt.
Was haben wir denn hier? 3,3 Volt innen.
Okay, nice. Das funktioniert echt ganz gut, hätte ich gerade gedacht. Das ist eine coole Idee. Das ist echt coole Idee.
Das ist echt nicht schlecht. Guck mal, das ist ganz gut geworden. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Das war eine gute Idee, Chat.
So und jetzt brauchen wir Ground. Da machen wir jetzt auch noch. Da ein bisschen dran.
Diese Dinger heizen ja ultra schnell. Wenn sie heizen. Auf. Das ist, by the way, deswegen sind diese Silikonmatten geil.
Eine Runde ein bisschen an Ground dran.
So und jetzt machen wir den Kram einfach zusammen und dann müsste das soweit so gut funktionieren.
Hey, das ist richtig gut. Das gefällt mir. Die Taktik gefällt mir. Das hat echt was. Fast besser als den Kram da drauf zu stecken.
Zumindest sparen wir da ein bisschen Platz, weil wir haben echt nicht viel Platz drin. So dann schließen wir das mal an und gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Okay. 3,3 Volt. Einmal Ground. So und jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage.
Es hängt jetzt ein bisschen Painschampig da. Jetzt ist die Frage. Geht es an? Müsste angehen.
Ground. 3,3 Volt. Output. Also von der Idee her. Wenn es angeht, seht ihr, dann blinkt es. Ach nee, im Moment bei 3,3 Volt blinkt das Board gar nicht.
Okay, jetzt ist die Frage. Monka, Smoke oder nicht?
Okay Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es funktioniert, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Weil das Board bei 3,3 Volt keine LEDs anmacht. Das zum Strom sparen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es funktioniert.
Ja, an was soll ich da was messen jetzt? Ich könnte an GPIO und Ground irgendwas messen oder so.
Okay, es ist ein bisschen warm, was dafür sprechen würde, dass die CPU angeht.
Oh, habt ihr gesehen, es hat geplinkt. Es hat geplinkt. Das blinkt ganz kurz. Okay, habt ihr es gesehen? Ich habe eben nicht hingekuckt.
Alter, warum? What? Hä? Hahaha. Warum? Alter.
Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? mentioning Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä? Hä?
sehen dass es funktioniert weil die led angegangen ist also was zum teufel ist
was ist das für chinesen scheiß wieder also wir haben definitiv das ist
definitiv richtig angeschlossen
wir haben es ja sogar noch gemessen dass das alles stimmt
hä
kann mir die china logik irgendjemand erklären warum das jetzt kaputt gegangen ist
oder das check ich nicht
das ist doch alles richtig
ok leute ich habe keine ahnung ich mache das jetzt noch mal an
ich mache es nicht noch mal an dann geht mir noch der das bord kaputt
ich schließe das bord mal ich schließe das bord mal per per usb an rechner
und gucke ob das noch funktioniert wenn ich ein usb kabel finde
der spannungsanteil ist das strom zu hoch gewesen naja aber ich mein von einem
angehenden esp 32 kann doch nicht sein
ok was passiert wenn ich das leuchten wir das ist das für ein krab
wir haben das doch vollkommen ok das ist doch vollkommen in ordnung was wir hier
gebaut haben ich verstehe es nicht ok ok leute wir schließen es mal in rechner
und gucken ob es noch funktioniert ich habe keinen bock dass ich mir jetzt noch
noch ein controller geschrottet habe mit was auch immer
wollt ihr wetten ob der controller noch geht oder nicht ja wettet mal was kann
dieser spannungswahl keine ahnung aber das kann doch nicht sein
haben wir den mod da der genau macht man umfrage ob der ob der controller ob der
controller noch geht oder nicht kaputt frage controller kaputt fragezeichen ja
nein
ja prädikten wir mal geht mal ihre prädiktions ab
hat irgendjemand eine glorreiche idee warum das gerade gesmokt hat
wette wette wette
geht an kontrolle leute sind wir äußerst zuversichtlich wie es aussieht
gibt es ein clip vom raum ein bisschen zurückspulen so leute ich werde es
erst einmal kurz ablöten die jumper kabels während die prediction läuft
könnt ja mal darauf achten wie es ausgeht ich will ich dass die irgendwie
dann auch zusammen gehen oder so ich habe keine ahnung warum das gesmokt hat
ergibt aus meiner sicht absolut keinen sinn absolut keinen sinn
ok was sagen die predictions ausgeglichen da ist er um den hier geht es hat
gesmokt aber ich glaube der kontrolle hat nicht gesmokt ok ist ziemlich 50 50 zu
jada geht geht noch und ja geht nicht also schauen wir mal
wobei ich kann den einfach am raspberry pi anschließen ich muss den gar nicht
am rechner anschließen ich schließe den raspberry pi an oder
sehen wir schon mal ob der prinzipiel angeht oder oder wild anfängt zu rauchen
wenn er anfängt zu rauchen ist ist schon mal gleich ripp
raspberry ok der moment der moment der wahre heit
ich würde sagen es stinkt noch nicht ich schließe den gleich mal am rechner
an und wir gucken wir gucken serial output oder so aber ich tendiere aktuell zu
das ding ist brutal heiß da stimmt irgendwas nicht
aber aber also das ding ist brutal heiß aber ich glaube nicht dass der kaputt
ist die dinger werden heiß so also man weiß man weiß noch nicht genau man
weiß nicht genau ok wir schließen den jetzt an rechner an wir schließen jetzt
ein rechner gucken ob er funktioniert wenn das serial wenn ich serial output
kriege ist auf jeden fall alles noch gut
da muss jetzt aber erst mal gucken dass ich hier was installiert bekomme für
serial output möglich dass die ganze wandler schade ja das kann doch nicht
sein warum hat das eben gesmokt ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn wir schließen
gleich das noch mal ohne an und gucken ob es dann funktioniert
na wenn er dem 12 12 volt um die oren gehauen hätte dann wäre kaputt
habe ich plattform plattform mal installiert ach nee
hat mal kurz installieren
hallo ja installier let's go gebe alles ein ein
loading reload alles klar plattform i o serial monitor ach nee ich muss das in
dem ne da ist es doch hier aber wie mache ich jetzt ein serial output von dem kram
noch mal schon eine weile her dass ich das verwendet habe ich war kurz bis sie
kleiner erst mal den kram hier schließen
auch ein neues projekt neues projekt so das ist ein board
lup finish so und jetzt waren wir einfach start serial und gucken ob es klappt
hier mal zu cd documents plattform i o projects und wie habe ich das jetzt
genannt plupp code plupp
ok das ist default not found ja was auch immer das da macht keine ahnung
sauce main ok schließt man gucken ob es funktioniert
alles klar connect zu poggers upload so wenn er upload geht ist alles in
ordnung mit dem controller
es kann auch sein dass es nicht richtig angesteckt ist dass ist so 50 50 ich
habe keine ahnung ob es kaputt ist oder nicht
ja genau wir können mal gucken ob das sich überhaupt angemeldet hat
ja also der funktioniert so halb halb noch so halbe halbe würde ich sagen
die rules passen doch doch ist alles gut
ich stöpsel noch mal ab und wieder dran können wir serial output machen
serial output beim anschließen an den moment das geht ja nicht
nein nein das geht ich ich ich mache die dinge immer in vm
ja ich habe keine ahnung ob der jetzt geht oder nicht also der blinkt und so also ich
würde ich tendiere dazu dass der noch geht
ich kann mal in man router gucken ob dass ich mit der firma die aktuell drauf
ist was gezogen hat an ip ich hatte nicht ne ne ne ne das funktioniert ich ich
für die dinger laufen also es riecht komisch das ding
ok da ist in so einem dessen so einem komischen state der controller
dessen so einem komischen state ich weiß nicht ob er ganz ist oder kaputt ist
er blinkt auf jeden fall noch
moment wie klingt man noch mal plattform ich muss mal kurz raussuchen wie man den
upload speed einstellen konnte wenn wir jetzt noch ein zweiter
controller wegen wegen chinesen wegen chinesen spannungswandler verreckt ist
dann ist die anzeige aber raus als an sich an alle an alle chinesen die
anzeige raus chinesen monitor flack upload speed flack
also es spricht ja schon mal dafür dass der nicht ganz im arsch sein kann wenn
er wenn er noch erkannt wird als als usb controller
ich starte die vm erneut aber ich verwende den immer in davor also das
funktioniert prinzipiell der blinkt auch noch an der led das kann doch nicht sein
also es kann durchaus sein dass wir die umfrage als ungültig machen müssen
weil ich keine ahnung ob die ob das ding jetzt geht oder nicht da muss man
keine treiber installieren der erkennt das ja guck der fgty usb
wohl wenn du nicht die cpu kaputt dafür blinkt mir aber auch ein bisschen zu
viel led und on board dinger da leuchtet alles und blinkt alles also das sieht
das sieht eher so aus als als ist ja was einfach mal reboot reboot hilft
oftmals das ding wird auf jeden fall echt heiß cpu technisch was das
eigentlich komische hintergrund heute ist ja weltfrauentag das bing bing image
of the day ist frauentag ich heißt es auch heute ist muttertag
ne oder das was anderes kann man
keine ahnung ob der kaputt ist leute ich ich weiß es nicht ich tendiere zu er ist
kaputt was aber widerspricht ist ich war noch mal rein raus was widerspricht ist
das alle leds und so noch blinken kannst du dir nicht durch messen da glaube
nicht dass ich da großartig was messen kann ob die cpu noch funktioniert oder
nicht es gibt bei den dingern kein eidl wenn du wenn du wenn er nichts macht da
läuft immer seine main loop und mit einem noob durch also bei den dinger
gibt es ja kein eidl in dem sinn ok wir machen jetzt mal eine sache ich
flashten mal übern raspberry pi sagt mir falls es anfängt zu smoken leute
ihr seht das bild nicht auch ich habe das habe ich das zugemacht
doch ich kann nur habe ich das zu aber ich habe neu gestartet lull keck wait
obs ninja und ich kann ich hier restore preview session machen auch nicht
wo ist wo ist mein obs ninja obs ninja der da komm lass den richtigen sein
excellent excellent ok picture in picture ich habe keinen bock das wegen
dem china kram das wieder im arsch ist da hätte ich echt keinen bock drauf
so seh den da leute da ist er da ist er und hier ist guckt mal da leuchtet noch
die led und alles und es blinkt auch noch die led für die main loop und so also
das das sieht so aus als geht's eigentlich noch
aber dass er sich von dem alten projekt was drauf ist über dhcp nichts sieht ist
schon mal merkwürdig ok wir sind wir sind wir sind auf dem raspberry pi drauf
also konnetten uns mal auf unser jubanto sudo ja ja ok das ist noch da ist noch
da wird passt mal auf jetzt mal ein big brain wir wir leiten jetzt den usb den
usb controller vom raspberry pi an die vm weiter richtig richtig exquisite
so
sagt mir falls er anfängt zu zu zu smoking da muss ich schnell rausziehen
also ok was muss man für usb ip machen
usb ip list nicht local host eins und zwei eins eins eins drei was glaube ich
kundnot connect ne was war das ubuntu et 1.113 ok da muss man das irgendwie
starten also ich mache das nach dieser anleitung gab es schon mal irgendwann
gebucht markt
kommen den usb anschluss vom raspberry pi weiterleiten da habe ich dir nämlich
auch mal drüber geflasht das weiß ich das funktioniert
zack
das ist richtig feifert ja usb list ja da ist er da ist er
usb i think's jawoll ein moment groß d demon export bind 1.3 ok und jetzt list
alles klar und jetzt können wir den einbinden
client mod probe lelux magic attach attach usb 121 113 131 1.3 gut ja jetzt
haben wir den jetzt haben wir den remote attached vom vom raspberry pi und jetzt
gucken wir mal ob wir jetzt flaschen können
leute leute ich glaube da ist rib es leckt stark ok wo da vorn please
wo da vorn alles gut an mir liegt es nicht keine package keine package tropfs
heute ist der ist kaputt
ich glaube dass das china zeug hatten gekrillt was ein scheiß ding alter was
ein ultra scheiß ding
gibt das das china zeug
also der ist der ist kaputt
das kabel das kabel habe ich vorhin benutzt zum flaschen ja und außerdem
meldet sich das ja auch an als usb gerät
näh also ist kaputt
ist kaputt
ist ja scheiße die chinesen die chinesen chinaware so jetzt machen wir
noch mal was anderes
jetzt machen wir noch was anderes zwar den schmeiß ich mal kurz in die eck so ich
will jetzt mal was gucken warum warum warum warum hat es gesmokt eben es
ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn dass es gesmokt hat wir messen das jetzt noch
mal
das ding das ist einfach der meinung gebadet
you got gebadet meint das was zieht er pico unterlast weiß ich nicht was was
kann dieser spannungswandel das das zeug das brauche so gut wie nix 150
milliampere oder so wenn es hochkommt
ja das funktioniert wir haben es ja vorhin gemessen
schiener schiener blies die chinesen alter wer kann so eine scheiße bauen
der spannungswandel ist kaputt das einfach verreckt und hat 12 volt durch
gehauen anstatt 3 die chinesen alter aber ihr wart live dabei wir haben nix
wir haben nix die chinesen wir haben es gemessen es hat funktioniert na alles
funktioniert und auf einmal und auf einmal bem ok aber wisst ihr was die
scheiße ist das ding geht nicht einfach kaputt du überlastest den safe wie kann
ich den überlassen das ist ein moment wir gucken uns jetzt mal die specks von
dem ding an wir gucken uns jetzt die specks von
diesem teil hier an
gucken uns jetzt die specks zusammen an ich muss auf meinen fack wie krieg ich
schon ich muss mich bei emerson anmelden aber emerson was ist denn das hier ich
finde das finde das in meiner historie noch die auflösung sagt heute ein
bisschen oder ok
diese teile sind das diese teile sind das akku man hat doch hat schon einer
gepostet ist das ist es auch ok ich mach mal immer mal aus dem chat auf genau
das ist was anderes das was anderes den da brauchen wir was sagen was sagen
denn amazon was das ding für specks hat ja kommt mal 0,8 amt ist das kann ich
eben das habe ich im leben nicht überlastet dass der esp der glüht
wahrscheinlich bei 0,8 das ding hat wenn es hochkommt bei der wlan übertragung
mal 150 170 milliampere also das ist ein bruchteil davon und sensoren hatten wir
nicht dran so und wisst ihr was das schlimme ist dass das ding nicht einfach
kaputt geht jetzt mal frage an euch ist das normal dass wenn
entspannungswander kaputt geht dass der anstatt kaputt zu gehen am output auf
einmal den input volt voltage hat sollte nicht einfach kaputt gehen also so so
richtig kaputt dass er das gerät dahinter nicht kaputt macht das das das
china zeug
alles ist verkackte china zeug der kram ist net billig der kram ist net billig
guck mal hier wenn du dir bei amazon de kauf was ich nicht mache ist nicht
verfügbar als amazon eu
beprüften sie die rechtsschreibung
kann man hier schön was bestellen ich meine hey der kram kostet neu 24
fund ok sagen wir mal so ich habe den bestimmt für um die 20 euro gekauft ich
habe gerade durch billigste china kacke 20 euro gegrillt 40 euro gegrillt
da noch der beweist dass es funktioniert hat
jaja genau da habe ich es angeschlossen und da waren es 3,3 ja ja genau
einfach bei 40 euro gegrillt
scheiß war er richtig reingeschissen ab ab wann ab wann verschicken die denn
kostenlos ab wann verschicken die kostenlos wo ist mein kard
stimmt bestimmt ab ab 100 oder so plus shipping wollte mich veräppeln
kosten das was kosten das shipping nach deutschland
ich habe noch welche aber trotzdem alter kann doch nicht sein
was kostet denn shipping shipping information
eur tracking über das mir egal kostet ja was interessiert mich nicht wie lange
das dauert was es kostet interessiert mich
during check out ja ich mache kann ich mache aber kein checker also es hat
gerade 40 40 euro das china zeugs
hätte da eine flinke sicherung abhilfe geschafft wahrscheinlich
oder man hätte auch ein ding ich kenne mich mit elektronik seine nicht so
dass es gibt doch auch so dinge die quasi das irgendwie über über eine
gewissen spanung dann dass es irgendwie über einer gewissen spanung nicht mehr
durch geht oder dass es ab einer gewissen spanung durchgeht
ach keine ahnung man könnte mehr hätte das bestimmt absichern können ja aber
ich habe nicht gedacht dass man das bei dem bei dem china kack von den chinesen
brauch top sehr zu empfehlen oh ja so richtig zu empfehlen richtig
nice schalten die scheine alle war weitem keine
ok das ist anscheinend muss es denn der pico sein naja ich habe zwei boards von
den geschrottet ich hätte schon gerne zwei boards wieder weil die dinge
unglaublich praktisch denn ich habe noch genug andere ich habe ich habe noch
keine ahnung 15 15 stück oder so also nicht pick und normale ja in allen
möglichen varianten das reicht
das reicht aber alle da wie mich das abfakt warum macht das china zeug den kram
kaputt top sehr zu empfehlen ja nee nicht zu empfehlen was sagen denn was
sagen die schlechten bewertungen so wir machen jetzt erstmal verweiten kein
totaler müll überlassen und facken ab ja
was das für ein kacken ob die dinger kannst du auseinander brechen das ist
nicht das problem an den dinger einfach mal einfach mal dran gezogen und
brechen die ab das ist kein ding danger non soddisfatto nicht zufrieden stellen
oder sowas wahrscheinlich 40 euro boards im arsch wegen china crap
der d1 mini ist cool der d1 mini ist massive geiler von denen habe ich auch
ein paar guck mal da liegt sogar hier liegt sogar noch einer irgendwo hier
guck da excellent ich nehme aber gerne sp 32 weil ich sp 32 angenehmer zu
programmieren findet als sp 2866 von denen hier von denen die habe ich auch
noch mehr als genug her aber ey was eine kacke das kann doch nicht sein
entweder so ein abo gewonnen bolbo oder es hat ja einer gegiftet
schau mal mini 360 die haben 3 ampere ja aber ich bräuchte ehrlich gesagt welche
die einfach nicht abkacken ich habe ja noch ein paar andere dinger ich habe ja
noch also es ist ja nicht so als wenn ich dachte nur die bieten sich an weil
diese schon klein sind guck mal ich habe hier beispielsweise noch ein paar noch
ein paar d1 mini power shields die sind so ganz praktisch hätte ich den kram
hätte ich den kram mal ordentlich gerade dran gelötet dann würde das auch
funktionieren aber exquisite load action also ich habe den power shield boards
noch am start ich habe auch noch ein paar andere die die ganz gut funktionieren
zum beispiel hier wartet mal ich hol mal kurz noch mal die magic die magic kiste
raus ja also die was das an und dem 1 mini die dinger hier sind die sind
tatsächlich ganz nice die sind es halt so groß ich wollte halt
deswegen den kleinen verwenden guck hier kannst du auch 12 in und du kriegst
quasi auch ein bisschen verbogen du kriegst mehrere crown pins sowohl 5 als
auch 3,3 und direkt die 12 raus die dinger sind auch cool aber die funktionieren
übrigens die habe ich schon habe ich so ein ding ist da gerade drin was was im
keller hängen das ist auch schienerkram aber auf
halb schienerkram von dem ich weiß dass der funktioniert aber was ein crap alter
jetzt ich habe zwei boards gekrillt und ich habe nichts verkehrt gemacht ich habe
den kram einfach so verwendet wie gedacht wie geht es weiter
keine ahnung nächster nächster nächstes board
nächstes board
ich habe ja gar nichts kaputt gemacht ich kann dann ich kann ja echt nichts
dafür das war alles richtig angeschlossen und es hat ja auch
funktioniert und aus irgendwelchen gründen wahrscheinlich weil wir es
überlastet haben ich denke mal ich denke mal der chat hat schon recht wir haben es
aus irgendwelchen gründen überlastet aber es ergibt keinen sinn dass wir es
überlastet haben mit dem teil
nächstes schrieben wir verklagen den china händler genau
ich hätte noch hier ein alter ich hätte hätte ich das genommen ohne scheiß
hätte ich mit dem auswählen dieses board brauche ich überhaupt nicht das habe ich
irgendwann bestellt aus irgendwo mit bestellt bei aliexpress weil ich mir
gedacht habe warum nicht ja es hat auch ein bisschen größer als deswegen sind
die tiny pico so nice die passen so kleine projekte halt gut rein was eine
kacke mann was eine kacke china kacke gibt es nicht
jeden youtuber das china kacke als format macht
und ich glaube das ist alexi beck sie oder nicht dann dann dann ich nehme
alles zurück den kuck ich nicht gerne aber es kann doch echt nicht sein es kann
doch nicht sein china krap alda
china krap
na ja leute wir machen jetzt nix mehr
wir machen das nächste mal ich packe jetzt den kram hier mal eine sonst dass ich
nächstes mal wieder finde all die dinger sind echt nice gabel aus eine
güte was eine kacke das rennt das nervt mich jetzt mal richtig er glaube ich
habe mir ich glaube ich hatte mir fünf stück bestellt zwei stück davon sind
das durch china kram einer ist an meiner led steuerung am fenster der andere ist
in der led steuerung vom weihnachtsbaum
ein habe ich noch
irgendwo keine ahnung wo aber irgendwo irgendwo habe ich noch ein was hast du
denn für eine led steuerung wled habe ich
moment habe ich wled mit dem d1 mini gemacht an weihnachten wir haben das
doch im stream gemacht habe ich es im d1 mini gemacht oder habe ich das mit
tiny pico gemacht an weihnachten
das freut mich wieso hast du auch eine waldemar wled
ne ne doch doch wir haben es mit ein wir haben das nicht mit mir sp 2866
wir haben das mit ja ja ich weiß noch wir mussten die leds nämlich wir mussten
nämlich die led die die pins irgendwie ummappen ich kann mich daran erinnern
ja ne ne ne wir haben das was ein paar leds ich habe aktuell zwei wie gesagt
für mein fenster und für weihnachtsbaum wobei der weihnachtsbaum jetzt gerade
nicht aktiv ist meine china kram wartet mal leute
sekunde sekunde das müssen wir jetzt noch machen
chinesen alter ich krieg es nicht mal kaputt aber abgemacht ging
die chinesen ok ich krieg es nicht kaputt ich habe so ordentlich gemacht
aber ach was ne kagge was ne kagge aber stabil ist es alda
china krab alda china krab billigster china kacke ok das kann ich auch mal
ablöten hier schnell bevor ich das das löte ich noch mal schnell ab weil das
teil brauche ich noch und den kram kann man vielleicht auch noch mal gebrauchene
perfekt china teil kommt in müll
meine güte was eine scheiße das regt mich jetzt richtig auf dass das abgeraucht ist
machs doch nicht kaputt ja kappa hd ich habe auch keinen bock jetzt weiter zu
machen ich hab grad wir bauen jetzt irgendwas
nicees und es funktioniert aber nein das china ding muss abfackeln guck mal
dieses kleine scheiß ding macht 20 euro einfach kaputt an die katzverfütter ja
genau das klingt sehr sinnvoll ok leute was habt ihr eben gesagt ist ein guter
spannungswandler für so klein scheiß also wenn dies sacken irgendwas was klein
ist und funktioniert wir können auch wir können auch auf 5 volt gucken es geht
beides
das flasche busy fett lm 111 moment es ist auch so ein ding was mir heute
abgeraucht ist oder
ich will an irgendwas kleines haben
lm gibt sie anscheinend nicht
jetzt die liveri wieder am start
das honest ja die müssen gut just honest die müssen gut sein ja ja ok was
hat was empfiehlt mit den amazon 12 volt 5 volt was ist das was ist das
usb auf der müsste ich dann noch usb rein machen das richtig hast du kaputt
gekommen ja das china ding ist abgeraucht das china ding ist aber ja von
denen das habe ich euch gerade gezeigt da habe ich ein paar von die sind
tatsächlich ganz ok was ist denn da für einen spannungswandler drauf bestimmt
der gleiche sieht genauso aus aber die dinger sehen alle so aus
ja das sind lm 111 woher weißt du das hast du den magic blick für oder
aber das ding sieht genauso aus auf dem anderen immer anhand der optik anhand
der optik können das nicht erkennen man guckt mal das sieht genauso aus
benutzt vielleicht ein buck converter ok 12 volt tut nach was suche ich da 12
buck hat man jemand irgendwie so big train nach was ich suchen kann so was
da mini mini 360 12 voll so was da ok die kosten ja auch schon da kosten halt
auf fünf so viel wie 50 bei den anderen was 12 voll step step down so was da
oder wie es ist egal 3,3 oder 5 macht ein kein unterschied also kann ich kann ich
beides verwenden mit 5 voll ist aber gar nicht schlecht und dann kann ich die
on board led verwenden ok was das hier wie groß sind die die sind schon eine
ganze ecke größer als das andere muss ich da erst selbst einstellen was raus
kommt na gut warum nicht ist doch eigentlich in ordnung das heißt ich
schließe dann mein 12 volt netzteil an
kannst auch kleinere nehmen ja wenn ich wüsste nach was ich suchen muss
excellent das sind schon mit die kleinsten die skip vom preis her hast du
irgendwo ein bisschen video material von einem wl project ich würde es dann auf
dem wl youtube channel hochladen ja aber der ist nicht wirklich das ist nicht
wirklich gut das video material was ich habe außerdem das will ich auch nicht
dass das jemand verwendet du kannst einfach die die die drehte ja das will
ich nicht das will ich nicht ich will da kein usb schalter noch ein usb bukse
reinbauen ich könnte ja vielleicht was aufnehmen
sag mal welcher welcher channel ist das auf youtube für mit ww led
ja offiziell oder offizielle bist du bist du wählt kontributor nach was muss
ich in der sucht offisch ja ich weiß nicht nach was ich suchen muss weil
vielleicht heißt das ding einfach vielleicht kann man so machen man kann
man channel zumindest mal zeigen
ach man ey warum meine zwei schönen boss alter zerstört von den chinesen
das ist die channel id ok wie kommt man bei youtube auf eine channel mit der
channel id habe ich noch nie gemacht ich bin kack kack oder stimmt er wird
warum wird da nicht gefunden normalerweise werden channels channel
namen klar am anfang angezeigt ah hier ok ok ja ne so schöne videos habe ich
davon nicht ich habe nur an weihnachten eins hochgeladen ich habe nur an
weihnachten eins hochgeladen wo ich gerade beim aufbau war wartet mal ich
kann es ich kann es jetzt jetzt wo man den wo man den wlad maintainer kann ich
mal kurz zeigen was ich da gebastelt habe an weihnachten ja irgendwo januar
januar das fand ich übelst lustig
wo ist 19 da wo habe ich wo habe ich gepostet wo ist wo ist das video von
man wlad alter wo ist es das ist weg das darf vielleicht wo ist es denn wo ist
mein wo ist das video das war im december das weiß ich ganz genau
hallo wo ist das video hin twitter please da ist es ok es war im november
so da habe ich da habe ich feuerwerk effekt gemacht am fenster aber das will
ich nicht dass man das irgendwo sieht das ist so dermaßen schlechte quali
alter ich dachte mir so wenn man in diesem jahr kein feuerwerk machen kann
kann man wenigstens led feuerwerk machen und außerdem habe ich das gar nicht mehr
so dran ich habe mittlerweile noch so wie wie wie wie wie heißt das so so so so
milch milchige leisten drüber dass das besser streut dass man nicht so die nicht
so nicht so die einzelne led sieht also ich habe ich habe so so leisten noch
drüber mittlerweile das ist schon nice wie gesagt weihnachtsbaum habe ich
genau den gleichen kram soll heute eine sache chat chat ihr müsst ihr müsst mal
was für mich ihr müsst mal was für mich erledigen chat chat ernsthaft jetzt wir
brauchen einmal f in den chat für meine zwei kaputten bords
pepehands
so ist das gut ja jetzt geht es jetzt geht es ja schon wieder ein bisschen
besser leute alter schiener ich hau da jetzt nicht drauf sonst tue ich mir noch
die hand weh was passiert ist
moment ich habe ein bisschen drauf gehauen ist
schon kaputt was kapiert kap passiert ist dass es in china spannungs wandler der
eigentlich von 12 voll auf 3,3 volt spannungs wandeln soll hat er auch
gemacht zumindest solange ich gemessen ab hat er das gemacht als ich dann was
angeschlossen hat war er der meinung ergibt jetzt einfach 12 volt aus und ich
habe mein bord gekillt
hast du den clip hast du den clip wo es anfängt zu rauchen zu zu rauchen
ich mein das ding könnte einfach kaputt gehen aber nein das grillt das bord
ok das gucken wir uns jetzt noch mal an moment das das gucken wir uns jetzt
noch mal an es hat geblinkt das blinkt ganz kurz ok habt es gesehen ich habe
eben nicht hingeguckt war das wo wo das ist einfach ich habe es eingesteckt ich
habe es eingesteckt es hat gesmogt
wo hingeguckt war das wo wo das mag warum ist das kaputt gegangen hat es
gesehen ich habe eben nicht hingeguckt war ich mein guck mal ich ziehe den
stecker raus ich ziehe den stecker raus steckt den stecker rein und es fängt an
zu brennen warum warum
smoke warum smoke warum guck mal vorher hat alles funktioniert das blinkt ganz
kurz ok habt es gesehen ich habe eben nicht hingeguckt das wo wo
Wie kann das sein, dass das exakt beim gleichen Ding abkackt danach?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich hab das reingesteckt, hat funktioniert.
Ich hab's rausgezogen und noch mal reingesteckt, das ist abgeraucht.
Und seht ihr diesen scheiß Spannungswandler?
Der tut hier auch noch so, als würde der funktionieren, guckt mal, der zeigt doch noch an, ok.
Sag mal, das sieht nur so aus, als würde das da, das ist nicht da, wo das raucht, das raucht
da und zieht hier hoch, das sieht aus, als würde das hier aus dem Stecker kommen, aber
das kommt hierher.
So und jetzt hat sich der Spannungswandler gedacht, ich geh nicht einfach nur selbst
kaputt, sondern ich mach auch noch 12 Volt am Output und grill das Board.
Wow, wow, Smoke, warum?
Alter, warum, what?
Das kann's echt nicht sein.
Das kann's einfach nicht sein.
Ich muss mir den Clip mal speichern, der ist lustig.
Es gibt ganz viele Leute, auch gerade in Science and Technology gibt's sogar paar Mädels,
so deutschsprachige und internationale, die Konter in der Richtung machen, aber ey, pff,
was ne Scheiße man, wisst ihr was mich am meisten nervt, gar nicht so sehr, dass sich
das 2 Boards abgeraucht sind, das nervt mich auch, 40€ und sonst wie, was mir viel mehr
auf den Sack geht ist, dass ich jetzt erstmal neue ordern muss und es wieder eine Woche
dauert.
Ok Leute, was bestell ich mir jetzt, sag mal irgendeinen guten, hier den da, ich mein
die sind größer, aber da kann sowas nicht passieren, und der macht 3 Ampere, das ist
eigentlich viel zu viel, aber ey, bei dem China Kram weißt du nie, 3 Ampere, man weiß
ja nie, wahrscheinlich schafft er 0,5, weil es China Kram ist, Mini, ok, du hast echt
mit den Mini dran, die Dinger hier, die sind tatsächlich kleiner.
Ok, wisst ihr was Leute, drauf geschissen, abgehakt, easy, ist halt kaputt gegangen,
man kann das Teil tiefer gehen als die Eingangsspannung, ne, achso, ja, es muss tiefer sein als die
Eingangsspannung, aber du kannst nicht über die Eingangsspannung gehen, also die Eingangsspannung
muss immer höher sein, als das was du konvertest.
Amazon, ok, zeig mal her, die sind günstiger, ja, keine Ahnung, mir war es aber größer,
ich hab mir gedacht, dass die hier gut reinpassen in das Gehäuse, ok, egal, abgehakt, wurscht,
egal, ich mach jetzt, was kann man hier auswählen, ah ja, hier ist der Crap, ne, hier, es ist
übrigens gar kein Bugmodul, das ist, ja, die wissen auch nicht was sie schreiben die
Chinesen, aber das ist so ein typischer China Titel, die schreiben da alles rein, bestell
dir ne neue Hose, warum, was hast du gegen die Hose, ich hab auch die gleiche Hose wieder
geguckt, guck mal, ja, ich glaub ich kann das jetzt zeigen, guck mal hier, war hier gleiche,
gleiche Hose wieder, Hose, Hose, weiß ich auch nicht, ich versuch grad den Fuß, ich
versuch grad den Fuß auf den Tisch zu machen, warte mal, hier gleiche, gleiche Hose, gleiche
Hose, Fuß, Alter, Fußlieg, ne, dicklieg geht nicht, dicklieg wäre Twitch Tossban, naja,
ok Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen, hab Hunger, hat leider nicht so funktioniert und warum,
weil es die Chinesen durch die Rechnung gemacht haben, China Sabotage, was für ne Multimeter,
irgendein China Ding, das kann ich dir zeigen noch schnell und zwar, das ist irgendein,
ein was, ein Track, hier, ein Tech, Track Life, irgendwas billiges, auch ein China Ding,
aber das funktioniert, Tech Life und dann, ja super, perfekt, steht nichtmal was drauf,
ach doch hier, DM01M, DM01M, aber das ist nicht gut, ich würd's nicht wirklich empfehlen,
das macht halt was ich machen will, aber das Gute ist wahrscheinlich nicht, ja, ich guck
mal, kann man irgendjemand hosten, den Friseur oder irgendjemand, mein Gottes ärgert mich
echt, egal, abgehakt, ich geh jetzt die restliche Nudel vor der Mittag futtern, ich hab die restliche
Nudel Packung aus meinem Probierpaket gefuttert heute, ja, Probierpaket, exellent, sag ich
euch, wenn ihr mal gute Nudeln haben wollt, dann holt euch, dann holt euch dieses Pack
gute Nudeln, gute Soßen, der Shop ist cancer, aber was willst du machen, ich find hier nie
was in dem Nudel, wo sie Nudel, oh diese Seite hier, ja, Probierpaket, Pasta und Soßen,
exellent, exellent, so heute hab ich die restlichen Spaghetti gefuttert, Spaghetti, Fusilli, Fusilli,
wie man das ausspricht, gibt's zwei Varianten, die Vollkorn und die normalen und heute hab
ich die restlichen Spaghetti gefuttert, die Ricatoni haben auch übelst gut geschmeckt,
richtig Porras, die Soßen muss ich sagen, also in diesem Probierpaket, die Soßen, äh,
also das war gut, das war gut und das war gut, das war eine relativ normale Tomatensoße,
die fand ich jetzt nicht so nice und die ging auch, aber also das und das ist gut, also
wenn ich, ich würde euch empfehlen nicht unbedingt das Probierpaket zu bestellen, außer ihr wollt
es wirklich, sondern ihr könnt direkt, direkt, ne, es gibt halt, es gibt halt hier 6 Packen
Spaghetti für 14 Euro, da kriegst du im Lidl, kriegst du es halt für 5, aber glaub mir,
die schmecken wirklich gut, die schmecken wirklich sehr nice, die Nudel von denen, es ist aber,
es ist aber nicht hauptsächlich irgendeine Nudelfabrik oder so, das ist glaube ich ein
Weingut, die auch Nudeln haben, die Seite kommt direkt aus den Häusern, ne, ne, die ist so
gemacht, ich weiß auch nicht warum, die ist nicht Web-Scale, die skaliert diagonal die
Seite, hat das Design, das Kind gesehen, ich glaub das ist Absicht, dass es so fancy aussieht,
so fancy, fancy, extravagant, ja, das ist not stonks die Seite, von der Optik her, wen kann
ich hausten, ja erzähl, mit Wix erstellt die Seite, ja, wahrscheinlich, debated, Digitalwelt
Original, sagt mir gar nix, sagt mir null, und wer bastelt, Projection TV, kenn ich auch
nicht, nur ich kenn einen Hosten, den ich, mit dem ich zumindest schon mal ein bisschen
was zu tun hatte, Arduino, Arduino Laser, schau aus dem 3D-Drucker, ok, der, der sieht
professioneller Streamer, der sieht aus als weißer, was er macht, den hausten wir jetzt,
den hier, bam, Raid, Projekt, wie gesagt, kenn ich nicht, aber wenn der Chat sagt, die
sind poggers, und der scheint ja auch wirklich zu wissen, was er hier macht, sieht schon,
sieht advanced aus, und bei dem raucht wenigstens der Controller auch nicht ab, nicht so wie
bei mir, also, rainen wir den mal, spampt, spampt mal, spampt mal eine Runde, wenn ihr
da hinkommt, Wupp, Wupp Pock, Wupp Pock Time, Alter, ok Leute, wir sehen uns, macht's gut,
bis der NCO, tschüss.